Evangelikale Netzwerke, das sind kirchliche Strömungen, die ein sehr tradiertes Rollenbild vertreten und oft auch nicht mit einer liberalen Gesellschaft vereinbar sind. Immer mehr Fußballer rechnen sich aber solchen Netzwerken zu. Dazu haben recherchiert Felix Michaelis, er ist freier Journalist, veröffentlicht viel zu Rechtsextremismus, Antisemitismus oder eben Evangelikalismus und Dina Falken, die hier unter Pseudonym teilnimmt. Ich würde sagen, wir legen mal los mit der Sendung. Werte Hörerinnen und Hörer, der Rasenfunk.
So, Borders in God ist ein Disziplin, der in der Welt des Fußballs ein Bewegungsmöglichkeit hat, aber es ist auch ein evangelistisches Bewegungsmöglichkeit, das die Messe erhält. Und du kannst das nicht verfilmt bekommen, ohne den Wort von Gott. Du kannst das nicht. Amen, Benik, Alter. Ich denke mir, Alter, erinnern wir uns mal, wenn wir 16, 17 Jahre alt sind.
Wenn du das gehört habt, über die werden wir gleich noch sprechen. Der bekannteste ist Felix Nmecha. Den haben wir ganz am Schluss gehört. John Bostock, das ist der Gründer der Bewegung Ballers in God. Und außerdem haben wir noch Benik Afobi gehört, einen Fußballspieler, der eben auch Teil dieser Gruppierung ist. Aber darum soll es dann später auch nochmal gehen. Erstmal sage ich herzlich willkommen Dina Falken. Schön, dass du im Rasenfunk mit dabei bist.
Ja, sehr gerne.
Und außerdem herzlich willkommen, Felix Michaelis. Schön, dass du da bist und hast auch schon zugegeben, Werder-Fan bist du. Können wir dich gleich zuordnen. Schön, dass du hier bist.
Das ist richtig. Ja, moin moin. Vielen Dank für die Einladung. Ich freue mich.
Ja, ich freue mich sehr mit euch über dieses Thema zu sprechen. Gleichzeitig ist es eine Sendung, die mich jetzt schon wirklich, also ich trage die im Kopf schon jetzt ein paar Wochen mit mir rum. Wir wissen ja auch schon sehr lange, dass es jetzt diesen Termin geben würde, weil es ein insofern heikles Thema ist, wie ich finde, weil wir hier über etwas sprechen, das eigentlich eine Privatsache ist, nämlich Glauben, aber dann ja doch eine gesellschaftliche Rolle spielt, wenn es die Freiheit anderer Menschen einschränkt und wir gleichzeitig hier über öffentliche Personen sprechen. Ich nehme an, Dina, dass das eigentlich auch so der Grundkonflikt von all euren Recherchen war. Ihr habt drei Artikel bisher dazu veröffentlicht. Ich werde die alle in den Show Notes verlinken. Wie gehst denn du ganz persönlich mit dieser Ambivalenz um?
Ja, es ist tatsächlich etwas, was unsere Recherchen so ein bisschen prägt und auch ein bisschen schwieriger macht. Wir versuchen, es sehr fair zu machen. Wir kennen es sauber. Was ist Fakt? Was ist Interpretation? Glaube ist legitim, er kann Halt geben. Wir verstehen jeden Spieler, der bei was Kraft zieht. Gleichzeitig ist es aber notwendig, die Missstände klar zu benennen und aufzuzeigen, gerade wenn es um Strukturen wie im Nachwuchsleistungszentren geht.
Felix, was sind so deine Gedanken zu dieser Dichotomie, die wir da haben? Öffentliches Interesse versus private, natürliche Meinungs- und Glaubensfreiheit?
Du sprichst das indirekt, implizit eigentlich schon direkt an. Also das ist der Vorwurf, der uns immer wieder begegnet, wenn wir diese Recherche veröffentlichen, dass Dina und ich als Ketzer dargestellt werden, also dass wir insgesamt was gegen Religion haben. Und deswegen hier vielleicht vorab direkt als Disclaimer. Es ist ganz, ganz wichtig, dass wir hier nicht über irgendwie normal friedlichgläubige Christen sprechen, sondern über ein, ja, man kann schon sagen, weltweit agierendes Netzwerk, was sehr regressive Ansichten hat. Und ja, wie gesagt, es ist etwas, was uns eigentlich die ganze Recherche so begleitet. Man kann sich das wirklich so vorstellen. Das sind dann teilweise Profile, die uns drohen oder beleidigen im Netz, die ein Profilbild haben von Enmetscher, was auch direkt irgendwie jetzt ohne was vorab zu greifen zeigt, wie wirkmächtig diese Vorbildfunktion ist und wie schwierig das Leutenfeld, das Vorbild, ja, von so kontroversen Themen zu trennen.
Ja, interessant. Und ich meine, es hat natürlich auch einen Grund, warum Dina hier unter Pseudonym auftritt. Aber da müssen wir, denke ich, nicht näher drauf eingehen. Jetzt ist es ja aber auch so, dass ja auch regressive Ansichten per se erlaubt sein müssen. Das ist ja klar. Dina, wo ziehst du denn da die Grenze? Und wo habt ihr die in euren Recherchen gezogen? Ab wann muss eine pluralistische Gesellschaft da dann Grenzen setzen und sagen, das ist jetzt nicht mehr von der Meinungsfreiheit gedeckt oder es darf sich nicht in gesellschaftliches Handeln umsetzen?
Ja, vor allem dort, wo dann halt die persönlichen Kontakte Einfluss schaffen, also wo es auch ein bisschen in Richtung Manipulation gehen könnte und wo dann halt auch dieses Weltbild dann eben auch gerade im Jugendkontext überhand nimmt und es dann halt auch bis zu einer leichten Gefahr für die Demokratie gehen kann.
Also kann man so sagen, Felix, wenn ich jetzt mal versuchen würde, so eine rote Linie zu definieren, da wo die Grundrechte und Menschenrechte anderer eingeschränkt werden durch Ansichten, die dann eben vielleicht auch besonders regressiv sind, da setzt dann eine Demokratie die Grenze und sagt, hier müssen wir auch dann die Minderheiten, die davon betroffenen Menschen schützen.
Ja, genauso ist es also mit Minderheiten oder Menschen, das muss man ja so ganz offen sagen, sind queere Menschen gemeint, also da, wo es den größten Konflikt gibt in dieser evangelikalen Ideologie, ist Homosexualität oder auch sehr veraltete traditionelle Geschlechterrollen. Und du sagst es eigentlich genau richtig, also Dina und ich hatten jetzt neulich ein Gespräch mit zwei Freiköchen-AussteigerInnen, die das sinngemäß genauso gesagt haben wie du, da wo die Rechte anderer eingeschränkt wird oder angegriffen werden, das betrifft wie gesagt meistens queere Personen, da sollte dann die Grenze gezogen werden zwischen legitiem Glauben und ja eben dieser interessierenden agierenden Ideologie.
Ja, der Glauben an sich, der darf ja legitiem sein, aber die Frage ist dann das gesellschaftliche Handeln, was daraus erwächst. Mich würde interessieren, wenn wir mal vielleicht, bevor wir dann richtig in die Materie reinsteigen, mich würde interessieren, wie eure Recherchen verlaufen sind. Dina, wenn du magst, darfst du mal anfangen. Wann seid ihr auf das Thema aufmerksam geworden? Wie ist es, in diesem Bereich zu recherchieren und dann auch zu veröffentlichen?
Ja, also bei mir hat das vor drei Jahren angefangen. Das war der Wechsel von Felix Nmecha zu Borussia Dortmund. Und ich als BVB-Fan, als queere BVB-Fan fand das natürlich nicht so cool. Da war er ja auch sehr oft in den Medien bezüglich queerfeindlichen Aussagen. Und dann habe ich das so ein bisschen angefangen zu recherchieren auf seinem Profil, habe da geschaut, was er so für Kontakte hat, wie man so folgt. Und bin dann auf Ballers in God gestoßen. Und das war dann so wie eine Art Rabbit Hole. Ich bin da immer tiefer reingegangen. Und für mich war das mega erschreckend, weil ich war da gar nicht in dieser Materie drin. Also Evangelikalismus war mir bis dahin gar nicht bekannt.
Und wie war es dann dazu zu veröffentlichen? Ist es schwierig, Medien zu finden, die mit euch kooperieren?
Sehr, ja sehr. Das war für mich eigentlich am Anfang das Wichtigste, dass ich gesagt habe, ich brauche Medien, das Thema muss Aufmerksamkeit kriegen. Ich habe dann verschiedene Zeitungen angeschrieben. Die meisten waren sehr interessiert. Und danach war es ihnen dann doch zu wenig greifbar. Die Religionsfreiheit war zu gross und das ganze Thema zu wenig Beweise am Anfang. Das habe ich mit Felix Hilfe zusammen jetzt auch erledigt. Ich habe dann selbst angefangen zu posten auf X, wo dann auch Felix drauf aufmerksam wurde. Dort hat er schon auch ziemlich Reichweite gekriegt. Es gab natürlich sehr viele Anfeindungen, weil wirklich jeder das Gefühl hatte, es geht mir nur darum, gegen Christentum zu sein. Das ist wirklich nicht der Punkt.
Das ist natürlich auch immer der einfachste Vorwurf, der einem gemacht werden kann, wenn man über so etwas spricht. Das gibt es in anderen gesellschaftlichen Kontexten ja durchaus auch. Ich will jetzt gerade, glaube ich, gar keine Beispiele nennen. Felix, das klingt jetzt so, als wärst du dann irgendwann mit dazugekommen. Und deswegen habe ich das auch vorhin vorgelesen. Also du gehst nicht an die gute Laune-Themen ran. Rechtsextremismus, Antisemitismus und jetzt eben Evangelikalismus. Du scheinst da eine dicke Haut zu haben. Wie bist du zu den Recherchen gekommen? Und wie schätzt denn du die Arbeit an diesem Thema ein, auch vielleicht im Vergleich zu den anderen Themenbereichen, die ich genannt habe?
Ja, mir bluten die Augen, mir bluten die Ohren. Das ist wirklich sehr zermürbend. Es macht mir schon Spaß, aber es ist ja, vor allen Dingen bei diesem Evangelikalismus-Thema. Ich glaube, das mit dem Antisemitismus, über dem ich viel versuche aufzuklären, ist wirklich das, wo ich mit Abstand die meisten Gegenden entbekomme. Im Prinzip hat Dina eigentlich schon die Geschichte, wie wir auf dieses Thema gekommen sind, ganz gut erzählt. Dina hat angefangen zu bloggen auf X, damals wirklich fast ohne Aufmerksamkeit. Also schon hat sie Reichweite gepostet, aber medial das Thema wurde überhaupt nicht aufgegriffen, bis ich dann zu Dina meinte bzw. es verfolgt habe und meinte, hey, lass uns doch mal zusammen da eine Recherche draus machen, weil tatsächlich zu dem Zeitpunkt ungefähr auch M. Bangula, Fußballspieler von Juventus Turin, zu Bremen gewechselt ist, also zu meinem Verein gewechselt ist, der auch Teil von Ballers and God ist, also eines dieser evangelikalen Netzwerke bzw. Gruppen, was dann für mich auch noch mal so ein Anstoß war, dieses Thema aufzugreifen. Du sagst, es ist auf jeden Fall sehr anstrengend, kriegen immer wieder sehr dämliche Kommentare, vor allen Dingen auf X, also auf Twitter, nach dem Motto, was ist denn mit dem Islam, was ist mit den bösen Moslems, also jetzt in Anführungszeichen so klassische What-about-ism- Argumentation, die sich im Prinzip eigentlich gar nicht so richtig mit den Inhalten auseinandersetzen.
Ja, und das Interessante bei diesen Kommentaren ist ja, dass wenn man genau dieses Gegenbeispiel antritt, ich glaube Alina Schwärmer hat das in dem Taz-Kommentar auch mal so formuliert, wenn du genau das Gegenbeispiel antrittst und sagst, dass was Christinnen und Christen im Fußball so zu ihrem Glauben sagen, über den Glauben in ihrem Beruf sagen, auch darüber sagen, wie sie vielleicht mit Mitspielerinnen ihren Glauben praktizieren. Wenn man sich das einfach mal in Anführungszeichen nur vorstellen würde, dass es dabei um den Islam ginge, dann wäre der Aufschrei ein ganz anderer und wahrscheinlich nochmal in eine ganz andere Richtung auch gehend. Und das zeigt ja auch schon, dass es hier auf jeden Fall auch eine Doppelbödigkeit gibt bzw. es gibt so eine Bigotterie, also Christentum, weil wir in einem christlich geprägten Land aufwachsen oder aufgewachsen sind, in dem allerdings auch inzwischen die Christen in der Minderheit sind. Also 44 Prozent aller Deutschen nur noch rechnen sich einer der katholischen oder der evangelischen Kirche zu. Deswegen sind wir eben entsprechend geprägt und haben dann vielleicht auch einen Bias schon in unserem Denken eingebaut. Felix?
Ja genau, zu dieser klassischen Bautism-Argumentation, was ich noch ergänzen wollte. Das bedeutet natürlich nicht, dass es nicht irgendwie Missionierung auch in Islam gibt, im Fußball, oder der Islam an sich auch gefährlich sein kann und es da wirklich sehr zu kritisierende Strömungen gerade auch in Deutschland gibt. Aber es ergibt keinen Sinn, das so gegenzuhalten. Das möchte ich dazu noch mal sagen.
Ja vor allem, es entwertet ja nichts an der Recherche.
Genau, das ist was ich meine.
Es gibt auch Islamgläubige, die vielleicht auch in ähnlichen Netzwerken hängen, aber darum geht es ja in euren Texten nicht. Jetzt sind bisher vor allem drei Texte erschienen, im September und Oktober 2025 und noch einer im Februar 2026. Wie gesagt, die werde ich alle verlinken, wie auch die weitere Literatur, die ich für diese Sendung hier konsumiert habe. Dina, ich hatte den Eindruck, dass dann das Thema doch irgendwann größer wurde. Kann man das zeitlich festmachen? Hört sich das auch mit deinem Empfinden?
Ich denke, das war, ich weiss jetzt aber das Datum nicht mehr. Letztes Jahr wahrscheinlich, das war dieser Tagesschaubeitrag. Und ich glaube, da hat es dann so richtig viel Aufmerksamkeit gekriegt bekommen. Gleichzeitig natürlich auch ist das Thema politisch größer geworden. Wir sehen es in den USA, wo die Evangelikalen Trump ein bisschen zur Wahl verholfen haben. Das heißt, Evangelikalismus wurde bekannter. Man kennt den Begriff jetzt. Man weiß so ein bisschen, um was es geht. Und die Tagesschau hat es dann halt mit Ballers in God und Felix Nmecha aufgegriffen. Und das hat dann schon noch eine ziemliche Welle ausgelöst.
Also dazu muss man vielleicht einordnet kurz sagen für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es gab einen Tagesschau Social-Media-Beitrag, der auch begleitend mit einem Text veröffentlicht wurde, an dem es eben sehr viel Kritik gab, bis hin zu einer Rundfunkratsbeschwerde eines CDU-Mitglieds. Eben genau aus den Vorwürfen, die ihr eigentlich gerade schon genannt habt, dass hier eben Christentum verunglümpft würde und so weiter und so fort. Und der hat eben hohe Wellen geschlagen und auch zu einer Debatte geführt innerhalb derjenigen, die sich dafür interessieren. Und Ausleser war eben wieder Felix Nmecha, der jetzt eben Spieler von Borussia Dortmund ist. Ich glaube, der unmittelbare Kontext damals war, glaube ich, die Ermordung von Charlie Kirk und dass er dazu sich nochmal geäußert hatte. Und das dann, glaube ich, der aktuelle Anlass für diesen Beitrag war. Aber damit sind wir eigentlich schon so ein bisschen im Thema drin. Und ich glaube, bevor wir dann die ganzen Netzwerke mal aufzählen und vielleicht auch ein paar Fallbeispiele nennen, lasst uns doch mal Begriffe klären. Was bedeutet denn Felix überhaupt Evangelikal und Evangelikalismus?
Also im Kern geht es erstmal um eine Strömung im Christentum, die die Bibel wörtlich auslegt, weist. Und das kann dazu führen, dass es regressive Ansichten gibt, vor allen Dingen, was Homosexualität angeht und Geschlechterrollen angeht. Vielleicht als Discläber noch. Dina und ich sind keine Theologinnen. Das heißt, es fällt uns schwer, irgendwie da eine fundierte Einschätzung dazu zu geben, eine fundierte Definition dazu zu geben. Das können andere sicher nicht deutlich besser als wir. Aber es ist eben wichtig zu wissen, das hatte ich jetzt anfangs auch schon betont, dass es nicht um normalgläubige Christen geht, sondern eben um aus meiner Sicht in weiten Teilen regressive Ideologie und Strömung.
Also es gibt dafür Definitionen in der Theologie. Ich habe ja auch durch meine Eltern einen theologischen Hintergrund. Deswegen konnte ich mir da ein bisschen ExpertInnenwissen auch noch dazuholen. Meistens spricht man so von vier Kernmerkmalen, die es im Evangelikalismus gibt. Das eine ist eben, das ist das ganz Zentrale, eine Bibeltreue bis dahin, dass eben die Bibel wörtlich genommen wird. Die Bibel letztlich als das Wort Gottes zählt, was wir in anderen Religionen kennen, aber eigentlich im Christentum nicht so ist. Die Bibel ist ein erst mündlich überliefertes Werk, das später verschriftlicht wurde und dementsprechend hat alles, was dort verschriftlicht wurde, in einem zeithistorischen und auch persönlich, nämlich vom Autor geprägten Kontext. Und der wird weggelassen beim Evangelikalismus. Es zählt tatsächlich die Silbe. Und innerhalb dieser Silben lässt man manchmal auch die paar Zwecke, die einem nicht so ganz passen, denn wer die Bibel aufmerksam liest, der sieht eigentlich, dass es eigentlich ein multiperspektivisches Werk ist. Dann gibt es eine Kreuzeszentralität, also der Heilige Geist, Jesus, und das spielt eine ganz große Rolle. Ganz oft sprechen auch Evangelikale davon, dass sie irgendein heiliges Geisterlebnis hatten, der Heilige Geist durch sie wirkt, oder auch Jesus oder Gott durch sie wirkt. Und dann, Dina ist, glaube ich, der dritte, beziehungsweise der dritte und der vierte Punkt gleichzeitig. Das ist dann nochmal ein ganz relevanter, denn Evangelikale, das sind nicht nur Menschen, die eben nach den beschriebenen Kriterien glauben, sondern sie verstehen es als ihre Aufgabe, andere Menschen zu bekehren, zu diesem Glauben und letztlich die Welt zu missionieren. Also es gibt da zum Teil Zitate, in denen, das heißt, allein 2,7 Milliarden Menschen haben noch nie Kontakt mit der einzig wahren Religion gehabt, nämlich unserer und unserer Religionsauslegung. Und das ist jetzt unsere Aufgabe, das zu tun.
Ja, genau. Missionieren ist ein sehr großer Punkt. Das ist so ein bisschen Pflicht auch, wenn man Evangelikal ist und in diesen Freikirchen ist. Es gibt da auch das Seven Mountain Mandate. Das sind so ein bisschen die sieben Einflüsse, sieben Bereiche in der Gesellschaft, die Christen erobern müssen. Ich versuche gerade zu finden, wo wir es haben. Das ist die Religion, die Familie, Medien, Wirtschaft, Politik, Kunst und Kultur und soziales Sport. Das sind die sieben gesellschaftlichen Schlüsselbereiche, die die Christen, die Evangelikalen erobern. Ich sage es wirklich, ich mache es und ihr seht es nicht, aber ich mache Anführungs- und Schlusszeichen. Das wird ihnen so vorgegeben. Man sieht das auch, wenn man zum Beispiel bei der Awakening-Church draufgeht, bei den verschiedenen Events, die diese anbieten. Da gibt es der Million-Month, wo sie in Europa versuchen, so viele Menschen wie möglich auf das Thema anzusprechen, auf der Straße draußen, während eines ganzen Monats, um die Mitglieder der ganzen Welt und von Gott, also von Jesus, zu überzeugen. Und die heilen dann auch die Menschen, denn Wunderheilung ist ja auch ein ganz großes Thema. Und da geht es wirklich auch um diese sieben Schlüsselbereiche und wirklich die ganze Welt zu retten.
Und das ist eben dann nochmal ein ganz entscheidender Punkt. Also ich denke, wir kommen da gleich nochmal zu politischen Dimensionen. Aber es ist eben das Ziel, gesellschaftliche Bereiche wirklich zu besetzen. Und damit, damit dann eben diese evangelikale Weltordnung letztlich herzustellen. Weil es gibt sie ja nicht in libertären Gesellschaften. Da gibt es ja viele Strömungen, die evangelikale ablehnen. Felix, du wolltest auch noch was ergänzen.
Ja, zwei Punkte wollte ich noch anbringen. Und zwar, ich glaube, einmal für diese Missionierung ist ganz wichtig, dass eine zentrale Idee von vielen evangelikalen Strömungen ist, dass sie den richtigen Glauben besitzen. Weil sie so nah an der Bibel sind, besitzen sie den richtigen Glauben und deshalb müssen sie die gesamte Menschheit davon überzeugen. Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen der Kerngedanke dahinter. Und das andere, was ich noch anbringen will, das ist jetzt nicht zwangsläufig ein Kriterium für evangelikale Strömungen, aber was bei Freikirchen auf jeden Fall noch wichtig ist, was immer wieder Aussteigerinnen erzählen, jetzt auch im Gespräch mit Dina und mir, dass es ja, also sektenähnliche Strukturen gibt, so ganz klassisch, was man eigentlich auch schon so im Kopf hat. Und eben auch sehr hierarchische Strukturen, was immer wieder Mitglieder in uns jetzt berichtet haben. Das ist denke ich auch nicht unwesentlich.
Und man hat jetzt dann die Problematik, und das ist wichtig, das eben einmal klarzumachen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass wir hier mit Begriffen arbeiten. Da gibt es Überschneidungen, aber seltene Deckungsgleichheit. Also sprich, Freikirchen, das sind all jene Christen, die nicht in der katholischen oder der evangelischen Kirche organisiert sind. Die haben Überschneidungen mit Evangelikalen. Also es gibt quasi Evangelikale, die auch sich als Freikirchen bezeichnen. Es ist aber nicht deckungsgleich. Genauso ist es andersherum. Und ähnlich ist es auch mit evangelikalischen Strömungen, mit eben dann, man nennt das, pfingstlich-charismatische Bewegungen. Das sind eben diejenigen, die tatsächlich an Wunder glauben, an Heilung glauben, die immer wieder Gottesbeweise in der Welt sehen und auch selbst ausführen. Auch da gibt es evangelikale Strömungen, die dieses Wunderelement, sage ich jetzt mal etwas flapsig, weglassen. Das heißt, wir bewegen uns hier eben in einem fließenden Bereich. Es ist hier kein Schwarz und Weiß. Und es ist auch nicht so, dass man das Menschen anhand ihrer Glaubensauslegung gleich ansieht, welche dahinterstehende Intention sie verfolgen. Was wir aber eben bei Evangelikalen besonders häufig sehen, ist eben tatsächlich eine politische Intention und eine gesellschaftliche Intention. Und da sind wir ja beim Seven Mountain Mandate, eben bei dem tatsächlich Ziel, gesellschaftliche Bereiche evangelikalisch zu besetzen, mit entsprechenden Einflussnehmern. Und Felix, da haben wir ja zur Veranschaulichung leider ein sehr, sehr gutes Beispiel. Ich glaube, gerade in den USA sind evangelikale Bewegungen schon gesellschaftlich viel, viel verbreiteter. Und letztlich haben sie in Anführungszeichen ihren Präsidenten zum zweiten Mal ins Weiße Haus gewählt. Das ist wahrscheinlich das beste Beispiel, um zu erklären, wie dann auch diese Einflussnahme politisch sich umsetzt.
Auf jeden Fall. Also zum Seven Mountain Dead sei noch gesagt, dass es sehr, sehr radikal formuliert ist. Es gibt verschiedene theologische Lehren, auch im Evangelikalismus, die quasi lehren, wie man Einfluss nehmen soll auf die Gesellschaft. Und das Seven Mountain Dead ist wirklich schon sehr, sehr radikal formuliert. Also wie Dina eben gesagt hat, steht wirklich, die Bereiche sollen erobert werden. Und genauso wird es dann eben auch umgesetzt. Das Kabinett um Trump, das kann man schon so sagen. Das sind eigentlich Evangelikale, auch Charlie Kirk, der ermordet wurde, den Nmecha dann getrauert hat. Deswegen passt es ideologisch auch so gut mit Nmecha. Ja, das sind von der Ideologie Evangelikale, das kann man so sagen.
Und wie sieht das eigentlich in Deutschland und Europa aus? Dina, ich weiß, dass das jetzt eine schwierige Frage ist, aber was wäre denn deine Antwort darauf?
Also, es gibt da schon einzelne evangelikale Strömungen, die da ein bisschen mit der AfD in Verbindung kommen. Das ist allerdings alles noch ziemlich schwach, sage ich jetzt mal so. Wir sind da noch lange nicht dort, wo jetzt die USA steht, aber die Richtung geht schon in die gleiche. Ich kann euch da aber wirklich FundiWatch empfehlen. Das ist ein Recherche-Kollektiv. Und sie decken diese Beziehungen zwischen evangelikalen Gruppierungen und politisch-rechten Parteien regelmäßig auf.
Felix?
Ja, direkt dazu einmal ergänzt. Es gibt in der AfD die sogenannten Christen in der AfD. Das ist ein Arbeitskreis, glaube ich, oder eine Gruppierung an AfD-Mitgliedern und Politikern. Und die suchen zum Beispiel immer wieder gezielt Kontakt mit der evangelikalen Strömung oder Kreisen und andersrum auch. Wie gesagt, schaut da gerne bei FundiWatch vorbei. Die arbeiten da sehr konkreter, deutlich konkreter als wir zu.
Das ZDF hat dazu auch mal eine Recherche veröffentlicht, in der es ein AfD-internes Papier gibt, wo eben Kirchen nahe Christen als mögliche Wählerinnen und Wähler der AfD identifiziert wurden. Dina?
Ja, das ist genau das, was ich jetzt noch sagen wollte. Die Ideologie ist ja ziemlich ähnlich. Also sowohl die AfD wie auch evangelikale Christen möchten ein traditionelles Familienbild, Mann und Frau, als Eltern, als Paar. Und sie zum Beispiel gegen Abtreibungen möchten eher ein bisschen in diese Richtung gehen. Also das passt da schon zusammen.
Und gleichzeitig ist es auch nicht nur die AfD. Also es gibt natürlich viele gläubige Christen, die aufgrund ihres Glaubens dann vielleicht auch anfällig klingt jetzt negativer geprägt, als ich meine, für evangeliskale Strömungen sind. Also wer Bibel treu lebt und wer an das Wort Gottes glaubt, der merkt vielleicht auch manchmal gar nicht, dass er über diese Treue und diesen Glauben an Jesus und an all das, was in der Bibel steht, dann manchmal hineingezogen wird in kirchliche Bewegungen. Da gibt es auch eine Schnittbänge an Freikirchen, die nicht auf den ersten Blick evangelikal sind, sage ich mal. Du gehst zu einem Gottesdienst und der ist einfach nur viel, viel toller als ein normaler evangelischer oder katholischer Gottesdienst. Es wird gesungen, es ist alles nicht so förmlich, du wirst wie ein Freund begrüßt und du merkst vielleicht erst sehr spät oder eben im schlimmsten Fall gar nicht, dass es dann bei Themen wie Homosexualität, andere Lebenskonzepte als Heterosexuelle, die Rolle der Frau, Fragen wie Abtreibung, dass es da dann auf einmal Ansichten gibt, die vielleicht viel radikaler sind als deine eigenen. Und dann kann es aber sein, Felix, man steckt schon drin.
Ja, das ist der ganz problematische Punkt, den du ansprichst. Und zwar, dass es genau diese Strömung, die jetzt rüber schrappt von den USA, so eine evangelikale Strömung, die sich sehr, sehr darum bemüht, modern und hip aufzutreten. Also man kann es wirklich sehen, zum Beispiel bei der Awakening Europe Bewegung, die hier in Deutschland mehrere freiköchliche Standorte hat, die inszenieren richtige Massenevents. Also da gibt es Dokus zu, das kann man sich anschauen, zum Beispiel von ProSieben, glaube ich. Wenn man sich das anschaut, wie diese Gottesdienste aussehen, das sieht aus wie ein Konzert oder wie so ein Massenevent, was gezielt so ein junges Publikum ansprechen soll. Und genau diese Art von Evangelikalen versucht, auch im Fußball anzudocken. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht ganz problematisch, weil dadurch dann eben, wie du sagtest, Leute reingezogen werden, zum Teil auch FußballerInnen, die in der Geschichte ja auch selber das Opfer sein können. Das muss man dazu sagen, reingezogen werden, ohne dass sie vielleicht gar nicht wissen, also ohne dass sie wissen, welche Ideologien dahinter stecken, sondern einfach durch dieses Gemeinschaftsgefühl und dieses Angebot reingeloggt werden.
Und dann kann es eben passieren, so wie in einer dieser Dokus geschehen, dass eine Reporterin, ich glaube, es war in der ZDF-Doku, vorgibt, homosexuell zu sein und dann wird ihr angeboten, ja, wir können Heilungsgebeten für dich sprechen und dich von dieser, in Anführungszeichen, Krankheit befreien. Und nach außen hin war es aber erst mal einfach nur ein tolles Erlebnis, ein schöner Gottesdienst und spricht da gar nichts gegen. Also man kann bei Gottesdiensten auch vieles schöner machen, als es in den Standardkirchen vollzogen wird. Aber das zeigt ja auch schon eben eine Entwicklung, Dina, die wir eben sehen. Also wie gesagt, an Glauben ist erst mal ja gar nichts zu kritisieren. Ich habe mir die rote Linie vorhin schon klar gemacht. Und so ist es ja auch bei einer, ich nenne es jetzt mal, Eventisierung von Glauben eben als Massenveranstaltung, als Gemeinschaftsveranstaltung, als eben auch etwas hipperes Glauben, als man es vielleicht auf BibelTV oder in der örtlichen Gemeinde bekommt. Ist das auch der Grund, warum der Fußball so attraktiv ist für evangelikale Strukturen? Oder woher glaubst du, kommt es, dass wir gerade in diesem Gesellschaftsbereich von einer deutlichen Durchsetzung, hätte ich jetzt mal gesagt, in Anführungszeichen sehen?
Ja, ich denke, es war halt auch schon immer Thema. Also man hat schon immer Fußballer gesehen, die sich nach einem Tor bekreuzigen oder gegen den Himmel zeigen oder so. Also das gab es schon immer. Fußball hat eine riesige Reichweite. Also ich glaube, das ist der meist gesehene Sport in Europa sicher. Und man spricht da halt wirklich viele Leute an. Die Fußballprofis haben eine extreme Vorbildfunktion, gerade für Jugendliche. Und gleichzeitig sind die Fußballprofis auch perfekt geeignet, um auf Glauben angesprochen zu werden. Weil die kommen früh in ein NLZ, die sind dann alleine, dann der ganze Erwartungsdruck. Man weiss nicht, ist man gut genug, schafft man es, oder dann kommt eine Verletzung und je nachdem ist die Karriere vorbei. Freunde fehlen so ein bisschen, ja, die Familie ist je nachdem weit weg. Und wenn man da eine Glaubensgemeinschaft hat, die wie eine zweite Familie funktioniert, die dich aufnimmt, wenn man durch die wirklich genommene Bibel so einen Leitfaden fürs Leben auch kriegt, denke ich, macht das vieles einfacher für diese Jugendlichen.
Wogegen ja, wie gesagt, vielleicht betone ich es über, aber ich will nochmal sagen, grundsätzlich zu glauben, das steht ja jedem frei, aber eben die Frage ist, glaubt man so, dass alle anderen auch ihre Freiheit ausleben dürfen oder setzt man dem dann irgendwelche Grenzen? Jetzt muss man dazu aber ja auch sagen, Felix, also ab 14 Jahren, in Deutschland zumindest, gelten Jugendliche als religionsmündig. Also dann dürfen sie sich auch ohne Einverständnis der Eltern taufen lassen. Es hat einen Grund, warum Konfirmation, Konvention und Firmung, warum das alles rund um dieses Alter herum stattfindet bzw. daraufhin abzielt. Das heißt, es ist ja wirklich, man hört das auch, ihr habt ja auch ganz viel die entsprechenden Podcasts und so weiter gehört. Und da wird fast immer davon gesprochen, dass die Fußballspielenden im Alter von 14, 15, oft 16 Jahren eben ihr Erweckungserlebnis hatten und dann zu Gott gefunden haben. Wie blickst du denn darauf? Da haben wir jetzt eigentlich wieder so ein Spannungsverhältnis aus. Einerseits eben man hat die Religionsmündigkeit, man soll und darf gerne tun, was man will. Gleichzeitig sprechen wir hier aber auch noch über Jugendliche, die ja auch einen besonderen Schutz, einen besonderen Schutz haben sollen, gerade wenn sie nicht bei den Eltern leben, zum Beispiel im Nachwuchsleistungszentrum. Wie blickst du darauf?
Also Dina hat es implizit schon angesprochen. Wir wissen von ein, zwei Personalien, dass sie in Nachwuchsleistungszentren arbeiten und gleichzeitig auch in missionarischen Kreisen aktiv sind. Und ja, also mir stellt sich die Frage, wie mündig ist man, wenn man eben psychisch sehr anfällig sein kann durch den Leistungsdruck, dadurch, dass man von Familie und Zuhause weit weg ist. Und ich habe mal mit einer Leserin tatsächlich darüber gesprochen, dass sie einen Freund hat, also ihr Ehemann, der erzählte ihr als Reaktion auf meinen Text, dass er zu seinem ehemaligen Fußballtrainer, also ehemaligen Jugendfußballtrainer bis heute noch sehr, sehr guten Kontakt pflegt. Es ist für ihn wie eine Vaterfigur. Das hat er so wirklich gesagt. Und dann habe ich so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht. Das kann ich eigentlich genauso unterschreiben. Wenn ich zurück daran denke, wie es bei mir in der Jugend im Fußball war, es war für mich auch absolut eine Vaterfigur. Und das darf halt, das darf auf gar keinen Fall ausgenutzt werden. Und ich glaube, es ist schon so, dass Jugendfußballerinnen hochgucken auf den Trainer oder auf die Funktionärinnen. Vor allen Dingen, wenn sie dann eben auch in diesen NLZs leben.
Und damit sind wir jetzt eigentlich schon in einem Themenbereich gelandet. Also wir alle, ich habe auch mit Hilfe der Rasenfunk Community ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die da mitgeholfen haben in den letzten Wochen. Wenn man einfach nur mal versucht herauszuarbeiten, was sind denn so Fußballspielerinnen und Fußballspieler und Trainerinnen und Trainer, die sich eben evangelikale Strukturen zumindest sympathisch gegenüber zeigen, geben sie z.B. entsprechenden Accounts-Folgen auf Instagram und so. Wir sprechen gleich noch über die Ballers in God ein bisschen ausführlicher. Dann kommt da schon relativ schnell eine relativ ausführliche Liste zustande. Also wir haben allein in der Rasenfunk Community ohne einen riesigen Rechercheaufwand 42 Männer und 15 Frauen herausgearbeitet. Und da sind eben nicht nur Felix Nmecha mit dabei, sondern eben auch jemand wie Davy Selke, Jonathan Tarr, Ruben Wagers oder beide Seiten der Frauen des Frauen-Nationalteams, der Humbert Giovanna Hoffmann und Sarahel Linder, die sich mindestens als sehr gläubig bezeichnen und in den allerallermeisten Fällen mindestens einer Organisation folgen, die in euren Texten immer wieder aufsaucht, Felix.
Ja, also Dina und ich haben inzwischen sogar so eine Excel-Tabelle angefertigt mit Spielern. Das ist also bei weitem nicht alles, aber es sind unfassbar viele. Es sind auch noch deutlich mehr als du es sagst. Es ist natürlich nicht per se problematisch, wenn die den irgendwie nur folgen auf Instagram oder so. Also ich habe ja schon angedeutet, die Spielerinnen können selber das Opfer sein in dieser Geschichte und diejenigen, die geschützt werden, sein sollten. Geschützt werden sollten. Aber gerade auch im Nachwuchsfußball, zum Beispiel bei Werder Bremen, um nochmal auf meinen Verein zurückzukommen, ist es so, dass es ganz viele Jugendspieler gibt, die religiös sind, das in ihrer Instagram-Biokonturen und eben diesen missionarischen Netzwerken, die du jetzt schon angesprochen hast, das Ballers in God folgen, also es sind wirklich sehr viele Spieler, Spielerinnen.
Und da gibt es ganz bestimmt auch noch eine Dunkelziffer. Jetzt würde ich gerne, bevor wir dann mal auf die Gruppierungen kommen, ich denke, wir sollten dann vor allem mit den Ballers in God mal anfangen, möchte ich noch einmal zwei, drei Worte dazu verlieren, zum Bezug zwischen Fußball und Glaube, denn der war immer schon größer als in manch andere Sportart. Also inzwischen ist es so, dass die FIFA religiöse Botschaften auf T-Shirts zum Beispiel verboten hat. Einer der Gründe dafür sind sehr, sehr viele südamerikanische Spieler, die rund um die Jahrtausendwende eben genau solche Botschaften transportiert haben. Also Spieler wie Roberto Lúcio oder Kaká ist zum Beispiel auch ein ganz wichtiger Spieler. Später auch jemand wie Marcelo Bordón. Das heißt, wir hatten immer schon gläubige Spieler, die zum Teil auch schon in Strukturen unterwegs waren, die nicht unbedingt evangelikal sein mussten, aber ähnliche Strukturen haben konnten. Also Marcelo Bordón zum Beispiel, man muss dazusagen, in Brasilien sind sogenannte pfingstliche Gemeinden sind in der Mehrheit und das ist dort, sind auch in der Politik vertreten, haben unter anderem Bolsonaro angeblich mit zur Wahl verholfen, zumindest haben sie ihn öffentlich unterstützt. Die großen Gemeinden, denen dann auch Radio- und Fernsehsender gehören. Also wir sprechen hier von riesigen Institutionen eigentlich. Bei vielen Fußballspielenden ist es so, so war es auch bei Marcelo Bordón. Das hat der Spiegel im Jahr 2008, glaube ich, heraus recherchiert, dass die zehn Prozent ihres Gehalts den Gemeinden überweisen, ohne genau zu wissen, was damit passiert. Also bei Marcelo Bordón, der sagt dann so, wahrscheinlich werden die Waisenhäuser damit bauen. De facto ist es so, dass zumindest der eine oder andere Prediger aus solchen Gemeinden manchmal mit großen Mengen an Bargeld schon mal festgesetzt wurde, beim Versuch dieses Bargeld über Kranzen zu verschieben, was auch immer man da rein jetzt interpretieren will. Aber es heißt zum Beispiel, dass allein KK in einem Jahr fast 800.000 US-Dollar an eine solche Gemeinde gespendet hat. Also wir sprechen hier auch über richtig finanzkräftige Strukturen. Und gleichzeitig ist es so, dass der Fußball aber auch darüber hinaus mit Glauben schon viel zu tun hatte, dass jetzt nur am Rande, aber es gibt in der Premier League ganze Vereine, die quasi früher Gemeinden waren und dann zum Fußballklub wurden. Und wir haben auch ein prominentes Beispiel dabei in der Männer Bundesliga, und zwar Borussia Dortmund, das auch aus einer katholischen Gemeinde heraus gegründet wurde. Interessanterweise dann in Abgrenzung durch Franz Jacobi zur Gemeinde. Also dadurch, dass der Pfarrer das nicht gut fand, dass Fußball gespielt wird, man hat ja auch noch einen anderen Blick damals auf Fußball gehabt, 1909, haben sie extra den Gottesdienst an die Zeit gelegt, in der eigentlich trainiert werden sollte oder im Fußball gespielt werden sollte. Und dann haben eben die entsprechenden Gründungsväter, ich glaube Mütter, war keine mit dabei, von Borussia Dortmund, haben gesagt, ok, dann gründen wir jetzt unseren Verein, jetzt habt ihr es geschafft. Es gibt dazu eine ganze Balesterer Ausgabe, Glaube im Spiel, die kann ich dazu sehr empfehlen, ist die Ausgabe Nummer 200, da wird das nochmal schön erklärt. Aber um jetzt diese Schleife zu schließen, sorry für den Monolog, aber es erklärt auch so ein bisschen, glaube ich, warum es auch gar nicht so eine Auffälligkeit gibt, wenn eben Fußballspielende sich zu ihrem Glauben bekennen, weil wir letztlich wahrscheinlich alle, die Fußball konsumiert haben, damit aufgewachsen sind. Wir alle kennen Spieler, die nach oben zeigen. Manchmal grüßen sie damit einen Verstorbenen, manchmal wollen sie damit aber auch zeigen, Gott ist dafür verantwortlich, dass ich gerade dieses Tor geschossen habe. Und damit meine ich nicht nur Diego Maradona bei irgendwelchen Weltmeisterschaften gegen England. Und jetzt landen wir in der Jetztzeit, Dina. Sorry für den langen Monolog. Und wir haben eine Gruppierung wie Ballers in God. Was muss man zu Ballers in God wissen?
Ja, gegründet wurde sie von Ex-Fußball-Profi John Bostock. Es ist eine Community rein für Profifußballspieler. Sie organisieren gemeinsame Retreats, also so Wochenenden oder Ferienwochen, wo sie gemeinsam in einem Hotel, in einem Ferienhaus sind und einfach beten. Sie haben Bibelgruppen, Verschiedenssprachige, also da gibt es eine holländische Bibelgruppe, eine französische, ich glaube auch eine deutsche. Und sie haben sogar einen eigenen Merchandise-Shop und sind auf Social Media sehr reichweitenstark. Sie haben knapp 730.000 Follower dort.
Und John Bostock, muss man dazu sagen, ist eben ein Fußballspieler, der galt mal als ein riesiges Talent in der Premier League. Er hat mit 16 Jahren für die Spurs debütiert und ich glaube vorher auch bei Crystal Palace. Da bin ich mir jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr so sicher. Ich habe mich nur mit dem Glauben von ihm befasst, nicht mit der Karriere. Allerdings, danach wurde aus dieser großen Karriere, er hatte sogar einen zehnjährigen Vertrag ursprünglich mal angeboten bekommen. Aus der Karriere wurde nichts und er hatte eben mit Rutschlägen zu kämpfen. Und ich finde das deswegen erwähnenswert. Felix war eigentlich interessiert, mich der Fußballer John Bostock gar nicht so sehr in dieser Folge. Ich finde es deswegen erwähnenswert, weil John Bostock ja auch mit seiner Biografie hausieren geht in dem Sinne, dass er anschlussfähig ist für ganz viele Fußballspieler, die es nicht geschafft haben. Also die eben sich zwar an Menschen wie Kaka zum Beispiel orientieren, so ist es John Bostock gegangen. Das sei sein Erweckungserlebnis gewesen, wie er zu Jesus Christus gefunden habe. Also ich zitiere ihn da jetzt indirekt. Aber die große Karriere wurde eben gar nicht daraus und vielleicht kommt daher auch so ein bisschen die Anschlussfähigkeit von einer Vereinigung, dass es eben jetzt nicht doof gesagt Lionel Messi ist, der sich hinsetzt und sagt, ja übrigens ich bin deshalb so gut, weil Gott durch meine Beine mit euch sprechen möchte, sondern es eben jemand ist, der eigentlich einen sehr steinigen Karriereweg hatte.
Ja, das mag gut sein. Tatsächlich ist es auch so ein Muster, was sich durch diese Organisation zieht. Also wir haben die andere Organisation noch, zu der wir gleich sicherlich kommen, mit dem Fußball mit Vision. Da ist ebenfalls ein Ex-Fußballprofi im Vorstand, beziehungsweise sogar als Gründer dieser Organisation aufgelistet. Also es gibt ganz viele Fußballprofis, die in diesen Organisationen betätigt sind, sie mitgegründet haben und dafür eine Position haben. Ich glaube, das ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, den du ansprichst, weil das ist im Prinzip dieses Versprechen, das die Gruppen zum Teil sogar explizit geben. Und zwar, wenn ihr zum richtigen Glauben findet und den richtigen Glauben richtig auslebt. Also hier nochmal Rückbezug auf die Definition, die wir am Anfang hatten. Dann läuft es auch sportlich bei euch. Das ist so ein bisschen dieser Kerngedanke dahinter.
Beziehungsweise manchmal ist es auch, leg dein Schicksal in die Hand Gottes. Also ich glaube, John Bostock, ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher, ich habe so viel von diesen Podcastfolgen gehört und ehrlich gesagt, das ist eigentlich immer dasselbe. Nur mit unterschiedlichen Namen. Also irgendjemand dort, der hat eben an einem schwierigen Punkt in seiner Karriere, er hatte keine Vertragsangebote, dann hat er gesagt, lieber Gott, wenn du möchtest, dass ich Pastor werde, dann gib mir jetzt kein Zeichen und dann hat er ein Vertragsangebot bekommen, hat vorher noch von irgendwie davon geträumt, dass es jemand in roten Shirts ist und wusste dann, okay, alles klar, Gott will, dass ich weiterspiele. Und dann hat er eben weitergespielt. Vielleicht spiele ich mal tatsächlich kurz ein Zitat von John Bostock ein. Das ist jetzt auf Englisch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich werde es danach im Groben übersetzen und damit wir einfach alle ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, wie jemand wie John Bostock spricht.
Ich gab mein Leben zu Jesus, als ich 16 war. Ich war überhaupt nicht in einer christlichen Familie. Und also wurde mein ganzes Leben auf mich als Fußballer gebaut, richtig? Ja. Meine Identität wurde auf ihn gebaut, wie ich John Bostock war, der Fußballer. Als ich Jesus wusste, erkannte ich, dass ich ein christlicher bin, der jetzt Fußball spielt. Und also war mein Geschenk jetzt zu werden, in einer Weise, die Gott glorifiziert hat.
Ich hab die Möglichkeit hier, dass er sich erst als Fußballspielender begriffen hätte, als Fußballspieler und er später dann gemerkt habe, durch ein Erweckungserlebnis eben im Alter von 16 Jahren, dass er eigentlich ein Christ sei, der auch Fußball spielt und dass er vorher getestet wurde von God. Also ich hab's eben schon angesprochen, er hatte eine steinige Karriere. Und dann kommen wir zu einem ganz interessanten Part an diesem O-Ton, weil man da nämlich merkt, wie schnell eine schöne Geschichte dann doch einer relativ fundamentalen Ansicht werden wird. Weil man sagt, meine Identität ist die eines Christen. Gott hat mich breaking apart, er hat mich auseinandergebrochen und er hat mich remolded like Christ. Also er hat mich wieder zusammengesetzt im Bildnis von Jesus Christus. Und deswegen hab ich diesen O-Ton hier mitgebracht, Felix, weil eigentlich hier innerhalb von 44 Sekunden aus einem, ich würde mal sagen, Glauben, wie ihn vielleicht auch viele haben, etwas wird, was zumindest in der Wortwahl doch ganz schön radikal ist.
Ja, was ich auch ganz interessant finde, ist, dass Bostock selbst so einen Erweckungsmoment, so einen Bekehrungsmoment anspricht, den du ja auch bei der Definition vorhin angesprochen hast, den ganz viele Evangelikale haben. Also so ein Begegnungsmoment mit dem Heiligen Geist, mit God whatever, den es bei Bostock scheinbar gegeben hat. Und du erzählst selber, das war ungefähr bei ihm im Alter von 16 Jahren. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, da war er auch gerade im NLZ, im Nachwuchsleistungszentrum, auf dem Weg Profifußballer zu werden. Und ich finde, das ist ja also diese Dynamik, die wahrscheinlich ganz klassisch ist, die man hier aufzeigen sollte.
Und es zeigt eben auch Dina, sie sammeln Gleichdenkende ein über eine Ähnlichkeit in der Biografie. Also ich hätte quasi von dieser Art O-Ton, jetzt nicht genau mit den Worten, aber hätte ich noch 15 bis 20 locker mitbringen können, allein aus den ganzen Ballers in God Podcast Folgen, die es gibt, weil das eben so ein klassisches Muster ist. Irgendwann in der Jugend, 15, 16, wir haben es schon angesprochen, zu dem Glauben, zu dieser Art Glauben gefunden und dann sie auch ausgelebt und gleichzeitig ist dem Teil des Glaubens immer so offen darüber zu reden. Deswegen gibt es ja auch wahrscheinlich diesen Podcast. Ich nehme an, ihr habt euch das genauso wie ich auch alles angetan vor eurer Recherchen. Wie findest du, wird denn dort überhaupt geredet bei den Ballers in God in diesem Podcast?
Ja, also sie sind wahnsinnig nah. Man denkt wirklich, man gehört dazu. Sie erzählen von ihrem Leben. Sie gehören da wirklich in die Tiefe. Es hat so ein bisschen was von der Predigt, aber auch, finde ich jetzt.
Amen, sage ich dazu nur. So wie sie es auch oft sagen, wenn jemand anderes etwas sagt. Und das zeigt sich eben auch daran, dass das ja auch der Anspruch ist. Wir hören mal in der ersten Folge von Bollers in God, in diesem Podcast. Ich möchte ihn nicht empfehlen an dieser Stelle, aber ich will die Quelle natürlich nennen. Da erzählt so ein Boss-Talk, wie es dann eben losgeht. Also wir haben jetzt gerade eben gehört, wie wurde er zum Christ? Und jetzt hören wir mal, was hat sich eigentlich mit dieser Idee, er hat dann ein, nennen wir es, Bibelkreis gegründet mit anderen Spielern in einer ihm ähnlichen Situation, nämlich weg von der Heimat. Es läuft eine Karriere nicht, aber ich bin eben sehr gläubig. Und was ist aus diesem Bibelkreis geworden? Hör mal rein.
Also, das Spiel von God ist ein Bezeichnungsschwerpunkt in der Welt des Fußballs, Aber es ist auch eine evangelistische Bewegung, die die Messe erzielt.
Denen, den wir dazu schon gehört haben, das war keiner von uns dreien, sondern das war der Moderator dieser Folge. Können wir ganz dankbar sein, Felix, dass er an der Stelle auch selber mal beschreibt, was Ballers in God ist, nämlich eine evangelikale Organisation. Man hat eben die Bibelgruppen, wir haben es ja vorhin schon erklärt, was Ballers in God so macht. Dazu gehören übrigens auch Taufen. Das ist auch diesen Kirchen inne, dass man sich dann im Erwachsenenalter taufen lässt, wenn man eben zum, in Anführungszeichen, Warenglauben gefunden hat. Und es zeigt aber eben das Missionarische, das in Ballers in God drinsteckt. Und das wird ja bei ihnen kombiniert. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was Ballers in God von anderen Netzwerken unterscheidet, mit einer sehr guten, würde ich sagen, jetzt neutral gesprochen, Social-Media-Strategie.
Ja, also die Missionierung von Ballers in God funktioniert eigentlich zum Großteil nur über Social Media. Das ist bei der deutschsprachigen, beim deutschsprachigen Netzwerk ähnlich. Aber sie sind, wie Dina vorhin schon gesagt hat, verdammt groß auf Social Media. Die haben um die 730.000 Follower, meine ich, und machen sehr, sehr viele Likes mit ihren Posts. Und das Ganze funktioniert so, zum Beispiel bei Torjubeln, wie du vorhin schon erzählt hast, bekennen sich Fußballerinnen zum Glauben. Manchmal tragen die Fußballerinnen zum Beispiel, ein Match heißt das beste Beispiel, tragen dann tatsächlich sogar Merch von Ballers in God. Also diesen Merch, den sie machen, das sind ja eigentlich auch so Fußball-Ausrüstung. Die machen zum Beispiel Schienbeinschoner, so Unter-C-Shirts und den präsentieren die Fußballerinnen zum Teil beim Glauben. Und Ballers in God nutzt diese Bilder und verwertet sie auf Social Media, um zu missionieren. Also schaut mal hier, der Fußballer hat sich bei seinem Torjubel zum Glauben bekannt. Und da ist auch wieder natürlich ein Problem. Wir wissen nicht, ob Ballers in God von jedem Fußballer, von jeder Fußballerin ein Einverständnis hat. Also das sind zum Teil auch Fußballerinnen, die sich beim Torjubel einfach so ganz klassisch wie man es kennt zum Glauben bekennen, die aber jetzt nicht unbedingt irgendwie krass Kontakte zu Ballers in God haben. Und eine weitere Missionierung, eine weitere Strategie der Missionierung sind sogenannte Zeugnisvideos. Es sind im Prinzip auch Videos, beziehungsweise da werden Fußballerinnen oder Funktionärinnen zum Teil auch vor die Kamera geholt, also von Ballers in God vor die Kamera geholt, oder auch von Fußball mit Visionen, wo sie über ihren Glaubensweg erklären oder erzählen sollen. Und meistens dann auch mit so einer Verknüpfung zu ihrer fußballerischen Karriere, also wie hat Gott derjenigen Person geholfen, in der Karriere voranzukommen. Das sind so die zwei Hauptmissionierungsstrategien. Und ich möchte vielleicht noch einmal auf dieses Zitat zurückkommen, um jetzt einen zu langen Monolog zu halten. Alles gut. Es wird ja darüber gesprochen, dass sie so einen Bibelkreis anbieten, so 7 Uhr morgens, oder so, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Und da wird meiner Meinung nach schon so ein Versagen seitens der Vereine ziemlich deutlich. Und zwar ist es ja so, dass es offensichtlich ein Bedürfnis nach Spiritualität gibt, seitens der SpielerInnen. Und das sollte eben eigentlich vom Verein, von den Verbänden kommen, also dass die da irgendwie ein Angebot liefern. Das wäre jetzt meine Einschätzung dazu, wie man vielleicht auch dieses Problem angehen kann.
Interessanterweise gibt es das bei manchen Fußballvereinen, gibt es Gebetsräume. Oft haben sie begonnen als christlich gemeinte Gebetsräume und wurden irgendwann zu konfessionslosen Räumen umgewidmet, Felix.
Ja, eine kleine Sache möchte ich noch anbringen zur Missionierung. Und zwar gibt es ein Post von Ballers and God selbst, wo sie erklären, wie FußballerInnen ihre Spielkameradinnen missionieren sollen in der Kabine. Und sie schreiben, jetzt muss ich jetzt selber nachgucken, aber die schreiben, dass christliche Fußballprofis auf, Zitat, offene Türen achten sollen und gezielt MitspielerInnen missionieren, über ihren psychischen Druck sprechen sollen. Also Zitat, sehe den Samen und lass Gott ihn wachsen. Das schreiben sie so auf Instagram. In einem Instagram-Post war das.
Und gleichzeitig könnte man ja aber sagen, Dina, wenn man sich jetzt damit noch nicht so sehr auseinandergesetzt hat, wie ihr beide, da ist ja erst mal überhaupt nichts dagegen zu sagen. Da sind eben Leute glaubig und finden Halt im Glauben und finden Halt in der Gemeinschaft, in der man sich dann zu beten und so weiter trifft. Und Ballers in God ist ja auch relativ klug darin, so wie es übrigens eigentlich allen diesen Evangelikern-Gruppen gemein ist, sich zu den Ansichten, die vielleicht auch vertreten werden durch ihren Glauben, nicht immer zu äußern. Also welche Anhaltspunkte gab es denn für euch überhaupt, zu sagen, Ballers in God, das ist nicht nur einfach eine Glaubensgemeinschaft, sondern das ist eben ein Netzwerk, das mit seinem missionarischen Eifer eben auch gegen Grundwerte der liberalen Gesellschaft vorgehen möchte.
Also Ballers in God ist da ja ein bisschen weniger vorsichtig, wie jetzt die anderen Plattformen, die es gibt. Sie haben doch problematische Posts zum Beispiel, wo sie ja in der Premier League, das war letztes Jahr denke ich, diese Rainbow Laces Kampagne abgeschafft. Also das war glaube ich ein Monat oder ein Spieltag. Und dann hat sich jedes Team, also die Kapitäne hatten eine Kapitänsbinde in den Regenbogenfarben und dann glaube ich sogar die Schnürsenkel, da bin ich mir jetzt aber nicht sicher, das nehme ich jetzt einfach vom Namen, waren auch in den Regenbogenfarben, das war wirklich so ein Tag für Vielfalt. Und dass dieser abgeschafft wurde, hat sich Ballers in God dazu sehr erfreut geäußert in einem Post. Ich weiß den genauen Wortlaut nicht mehr, aber ich meinte, sie haben gesagt, wir haben gefastet, wir haben gebetet und God hat uns gehört.
Mit eben dem Post zu der Absage dieser Kampagne, dass die Prämie das zumindest mit der Organisation nicht mehr weitermacht, die das bisher durchgeführt hat.
Genau. Und natürlich gehört dazu ja auch die große Nähe zur Awakening-Church, zu Ben Fitzgerald, der ja auch zur Bethel-Church gehört. Das sind dann schon sehr klare evangelikale Communities.
Ich würde sagen, lasst uns zu diesem Punkt jetzt nämlich wirklich mal kommen. Weil eben, also wir haben eben dieses Posting, wo sie es gefeiert haben, dass eben ein Zeichen gegen Queerfeindlichkeit, gegen Diskriminierung abgeschafft wurde. Beziehungsweise man muss vorsichtig sein. Die Prämie League hat es mit dieser Organisation, wollte es nicht mehr weiterführen. So wie es aber aktuell aussieht, will die Prämie League im eigenen Sinne noch eine solche Aktion machen. Aber das wurde eben nicht nur entsprechend kommentiert von Ballers in God, sondern auch, zumindest von außen sieht es so aus, systematisch vorbereitet, indem eben jene Kapitäne, die sich solchen Gruppierungen zugehörig fuhren, die Regenbogenbinde in ihrem Zweck entfremdet haben, indem sie draufgeschrieben haben, ich glaube, I love Jesus oder God loves me. Also eben ihre eigenen Botschaften draufgeschrieben haben, was ja ein Zeichen ist, wenn man sagt, hinter diesem Zeichen stehe ich nicht ohne noch etwas anderes damit verbinden zu können. Da ging es natürlich darum, das in Frage zu stellen. Ansonsten musst du da nicht zusätzlich noch was draufschreiben. Und das ist eben das eine, wo man eindeutige Tendenzen, queervandliche Tendenzen nachweisen kann. Und das andere sind dann eben personale Verstrickungen. Felix, wenn du magst, wenn du dich traust, denn es ist ein komplexes Thema, magst du uns die Bethel Church und woran da geglaubt wird, mit ein paar Worten näherbringen? Und dann können wir kurz erklären, was die jetzt mit Ballers in God genau zu tun haben.
Also die Bethel Church selbst hängt gar nicht direkt mit Ballers in God zusammen. Es ist, wie gesagt, diese Reckoning Bewegung, die Reckoning Church auch genannt wird. Also das ist eine Bewegung, die verschiedene freikirchische Standorte hat, unter anderem jetzt auch in Europa und in Deutschland. Und diese Verbindung ist personell bestätigt durch John Bostock, also der John Bostock pflegt gute Kontakte zu Ben Fitzgerald. Und wie Dina schon gesagt hat, dieser Ben Fitzgerald ist sozusagen der Leiter dieser Reckoning Bewegung. Zum Beispiel gab es da Posts von Ballers in God, wo sie gesagt haben, dass Ben Fitzgerald ein enger Freund der Community ist, ein guter Kontakt ist. Also das schreiben sie so selbst. Es gab beim Champions League Finale, wo der BVB mit dabei war, das war 2024. Da war John Bostock eingeladen. Also John Bostock von Ballers in God war eingeladen, von Felix Nmecha eingeladen. Gemeinsam mit Ben Fitzgerald. Also da, um erstmal klarzumachen, ja, diese Verbindungen, die haben wir nicht irgendwie fantasiert, die gibt es tatsächlich. So, und die Awakening-Bewegung ist eine extrem charismatische evangelikale Bewegung. Das bedeutet, das hatten wir vorhin auch schon in der Definition, sie setzen auf Wunderheilungen. Gibt es auch Aussteiger in Geschichten zu, wie diese Wunderheilungen ausgenutzt worden sind? Zum Beispiel hat ein Bruder von einem Aussteiger berichtet, dass, wie gesagt, sein Bruder eine Krebserkrankung hat und dass dieser Ben Fitzgerald das sehr ausgenutzt haben soll. Zu extrem charismatisch gehört aber auch so etwas wie Exorzismen, also Teufelsaustreibungen. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch traditionelle Geschlechterrollen und eine Ablehnung von queeren Rechten. Das ist auch in der Wackening-Bewegung vorhanden. Und auch sehr strikte Hierarchien, was Aussteigerinnen immer berichten. Was vielleicht bei Borders and God noch ganz interessant ist, und das ist etwas, was auch für Fußball mit Vision gilt, ist, dass sich die Problematik auch durch einzelne Personen verkörpert. Zum Beispiel gibt es Nmecha, ich bringe ihn immer wieder an, aber er ist immer das einfachste Beispiel, der sich wirklich sehr unmissverständlich offen queerfeindlich geäußert hat. Zum Beispiel dadurch, dass er die Pride-Bewegung mit dem Teufel gleich gesetzt hat, dass er sich abblitzen lassen hat mutmaßlich mit einem frauenfeindlichen Buch, dass er Likes gesetzt hat unter Posts, wo Konversionstherapien oder Homosexualität offen verneint wurde. Ja, also es zeigt sich auf jeden Fall auch durch einzelne Personalien, die... Was ist das bei Nmecha so? Der hat tatsächlich eine Führungsrolle bei Ballers and God und tritt auch noch für Fußball mit Visionen auf. Also da gibt es diese drei Anhaltspunkte. Einerseits Ballers and God, die selbst zum Teil kritische Posts raushauen. Dann der Kontakt zur freikirchlichen Bewegung, zur Reckoning-Bewegung und einzelne Personalien, die das verkörpern. Also diese drei kritischen Stichpunkte haben wir da. Und das gilt für Fußball mit Visionen eigentlich im Grunde genauso.
Also zu Felix Nmecha, dazu muss man sagen, er hat dann später bezogen auf dieses Posting, in dem er eben das Wort Pride, das er eine eindeutige Bewegung in der queeren Community hat, mit dem Teufel gleichgesetzt hat, dass er sagen wollte, dass er das nicht das damit sagen wollte, was wir jetzt gerade hineingelesen haben. Das gehört mit dazu, das zu sagen. Aber ich habe noch, brauchst gar nicht mit dem Kopf schütteln Felix, ich habe noch ein paar Zitate von ihm mitgebracht. Ich glaube, wir können schon ganz gut einordnen, wo Felix Nmecha da steht, da machen wir vielleicht gleich einen eigenen Blog. Kurz zur Bethel-Church, um das jetzt klar zu machen, warum ich auch quasi jetzt bis in die USA rübergegangen bin, um eben quasi Balles in God hier in Europa zu erklären. Also zum einen muss einem klar sein, wie radikal die sind. Also die glauben auch an toten Auferweckungen. Die glauben an Prophezeiungen und die sind in Kalifornien extrem groß aufgestellt. Also die betreiben eigene Schulen. Sie haben ein eigenes Supernatural Ministry, in dem eben dann Missionare ausgebildet werden und die werden in die ganze Welt geschickt. Und einer dieser Missionare, das ist eben Ben Fitzgerald, der angeblich 2014 eine Vision von Jesus bekommen habe, der eben gesagt hätte, so jetzt gehst du noch Europa und missionierst Europa. Also deswegen aus diesem, aus dieser Wurzel kommt eben Ben Fitzgerald. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das noch ergänzen wolltest, Felix.
Ja, genau. Ich hatte jetzt eben so viel geredet, dass ich den Punkt vergessen hatte mit der Bethel Church, was du eigentlich gefragt hattest. Genau das ist es. Also die Verbindung ergibt sich dadurch, dass der Ben Fitzgerald von der Bethel Church ausgebildet ist und mutmaßlich auch immer noch Kontakte dafür legt. Er wurde, Zitat, das schreiben sie so selbst, ausgesendet, um Europa zu bekehren, whatever. Und die Bethel Church ist diejenige Freiküche, die ganz offen auch schreibt, dass sie diese theologische Lehre vom Seven Mountain, der sie lernt, also das, was Dina vorhin angebracht hatte von der Eroberung der sieben gesellschaftlichen Schlüsselbereiche, wo der Fußball dann irgendwo bei Gesellschaft auch dazwischenfällt.
Und damit eben dann eine Missionierung der kompletten Werte. Und so ist eben quasi diese US-evangelikalische Strömung, evangelikale Strömung, in Europa gelandet. Und dort gibt es eben die klare Verbindung zwischen John Bostock und Ben Fitzgerald. Du hast ja schon ein paar der Momente genannt, aber sie verheimlichen das ja auch nicht. Also sie posten ja gemeinsame Postings, sprechen auch gegenseitig, bewundern voneinander. Und vielleicht, um so nochmal einen Eindruck dafür zu bekommen, wieso der Geist ist von jemandem wie John Bostock, habe ich nochmal zwei ganz kurze Zitate mitgebracht. Da können wir mal noch kurz reinhören. Und dann, Dina, wird mich auch deine Meinung dazu interessieren, wie du ihn als Figur einschätzt. Da haben wir eben einmal der Anspruch, die Massen zu erreichen. Und er hat unter anderem einmal Folgendes hier gesagt.
Glaub Gott für Erwachsenisse.
Also wenn man es jetzt übertrieben formulieren will, eine wissenschaftsfeindliche Haltung.
Ja, also ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob John Bostock wissenschaftsfeindlich ist. Aber es gehört halt auch ein bisschen zur Bethel Church, zur Awakening Church, dass man da sich ein bisschen wissenschaftsfeindlich zeigt. Wie sonst würden Sie die Wunderheilungen von blinden Personen, von Krebskranken erklären, die Sie angeblich hier haben? Und ich denke schon auch, dass das wirklich so ein zentraler Punkt ist von diesem, ich sage es jetzt mal radikalen Evangelikalismus.
Und ja, Felix?
Vielleicht um an diese Wunderheilungen noch anzuknüpfen. Ich hatte ja vorhin davon gesprochen, dass es so Konzertartige Massenevents sind. Und diese Wunderheilungen und Exorzismen, die passieren dann auch innerhalb dieser Events. Also das sollten sich die Zuschauer wirklich mal irgendwie eine Doku zu angucken. Das ist total interessant zu sehen und wahrscheinlich für die meisten auch befremdlich, die da nichts mit zu tun haben, wie das aussieht, wenn da irgendwie so Exorzismen oder Wunderheilungen gemacht werden. Und wie die Leute da irgendwie rumschreien und das austreiben, das ist gar nicht so richtig in Worte zu fassen.
Ja, also das hat seine eigene Faszination, möchte ich mal sagen. Und wichtig ist eben der missionarische Gedanke. Egal wann der bei John Bostock sich bei Ballers in God manifestiert hat, vielleicht war es ja wirklich am Anfang in Anführungszeichen nur ein Bibelkreis mit Gleichgesinnten. Es geht vor allem eben darum, Menschen zu erreichen. Und sie ziehen immer auf Jugend. Das sind auch jugendliche Bewegungen. Und dazu habe ich nochmal ein Beispiel mitgebracht. Das haben wir vorhin im Intro schon mal kurz gehört. Da spricht erst Benik Afobi und dann antwortet ihm John Bostock. Letztlich zeigt er eigentlich sehr offen, was er erreichen möchte.
Du wirst aufgewachsen, es werden bessere Spieler als wir sein. Du wirst besser Fußballer als wir sein, es werden mehr Menschen, die mehr Geld haben als wir. Aber der Passionsschutz für Gott muss da sein und dein Leben wird erfüllt. Und du kannst das Fulfilment ohne den Wort von Gott nicht bekommen. Du kannst das nicht. Amen, Amen, Benek, Bro. Wir sind 16, 17 Jahre alt.
Ich fasse noch mal ganz kurz zusammen für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, denen es auf Englisch jetzt zu schnell ging. Benik Afobi sagt, überleg einfach mal, wie viele Fußballspieler es da draußen gibt, wie viele Menschen wir erreichen können mit der Botschaft Gottes, mit dem, was wir tun. Und John Bostock sagt in der ihm eigenen Art, Amen, armen Bruder. Überleg mal, wenn wir dieses Video hier mit 16 Jahren gesehen hätten, was das mit uns gemacht hatte. Und das zeigt ja Dina, warum. Wir haben schon mal über Nachwuchsleistungszentren und Jugendlichkeit gesprochen. Aber warum es vielleicht wirklich eine Pflicht wäre, dass auch alle Menschen, die sich in solchen Strukturen bewegen, zumindest wissen, dass es solche Bewegungen gibt und eben auch die Gefahren, die da drin liegen können. Denn wie gesagt, von außen sieht ja alles immer erst mal einfach nur hip und christlich und gemeinschaftlich aus. Es kann aber auch in ganz extreme Sphären reingehen.
Ja, und ich finde, das sind die Vereine wirklich in der Pflicht. Ich habe mir schon ein paar von diesen Schutzkonzepten von verschiedenen NLZs angeschaut und dieses Thema kommt da einfach gar nicht vor. Also es wird zwar vor Diskriminierung geschützt, aber dass es da auch manipulative religiöse Einflüsse geben kann, das ist nicht Thema. Und ich verstehe ja jeden Jugendspieler, der sich das wirklich anschaut und denkt, oh, das ist cool, da möchte ich dabei sein, das gibt mir Halt, das ist eine Familie. Und das liegt da wirklich an den Vereinen, dass man da aufklärt, dass man vielleicht gute Alternativen bietet. Wie gesagt, Glaube an sich ist ja nicht falsch und auch nicht gefährlich. Und dass man vielleicht auch eine Ansprechperson hat im Verein für solche Themen.
Und dann, ich würde vorschlagen, wir gehen mal noch ein paar Gruppierungen durch, die es sonst noch so gibt, weil es sind nicht nur die Ballers in God. Und dann habe ich noch ein paar Felix Nmecha Zitate mitgebracht, um auch so ein bisschen den Ton zu setzen, auch warum letztlich es auch zu euren Recherchen gekommen ist. Wir haben zum Beispiel Felix noch die God's Power Germany. Was ist denn die God's Power Germany?
Das ist tatsächlich eine der Initiativen, die wir in unseren Recherchen eigentlich fast gar nicht erwähnt haben, weil die bisher auch eher unauffällig und, ich will nicht sagen irrelevant, aber auf jeden Fall eher eine kleinere Initiative sind. Die haben knapp 7000 Follow-In auf Instagram. Das ist wie der Name schon verreden, Deutschsprachige Initiative zur Missionierung. Der Gründer ist Jake Bokey. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich ihn richtig ausspreche. Und der tritt unter anderem auch als Redner, zum Beispiel bei der Church of Pentecost Germany auf. Im Vergleich zu anderen Gruppen sind sie bisher aber weniger aktiv und relevant. Da gäbe es in Deutschland zum Beispiel Fußballmitvisionen, die da deutlich größer sind, mit denen wir uns mehr beschäftigt haben.
Ich will kurz ganz kurz erklären, warum ich die hier mit genannt habe. Weil hier haben wir mal einen von ganz wenigen Fällen, in denen es ein Posting gab bei dem Spieler, in dem Fall Spieler der U19 von Union Berlin aus dem Männerteam, eben von God's Power Germany verwendet wurden, um Werbung dafür zu machen. Und der Verein ist tatsächlich eingestritten. Ich weiß nicht, Dina, inwieweit ihr da involviert war, das mitverfolgt habt?
Ich habe es gesehen. Ich habe auch Union Berlin angeschrieben und darauf hingewiesen. Und sie haben dann, ich weiß, es ist schon so lange her und es ist so viel passiert, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, was sie geantwortet haben. Aber ich weiß, es war so in der Richtung von, wir haben damit nichts zu tun. Und sie schauen, dass der Post gelöscht wird.
Und das ist dann auch passiert. Und danach haben sie gesagt, wir sind frei von religiösen Botschaften. Das war quasi die Begründung, mit der man das getan hat. Aber deswegen wollte ich das eben hier mal nennen, weil da tatsächlich mal ein Verein tätig geworden ist. Eigentlich fast allen anderen Beispielen, über die wir jetzt reden, haben Vereine höchstens auf öffentlichen Druck hin. Das war dann ja unter anderem auch bei Felix Nmecha der Fall, sich mal geäußert. Felix, du hast schon mehrfach Fußball mit Vision erwähnt. Was ist das für eine Gruppierung? Was müssen wir über die wissen?
Das ist eine deutschsprachige Plattform für Missionierung und es ist ein formal eingetragener Verein der Gründer. Und ja, Vorsitzende ist Manuel Büller, der ist auch Theologe. Und hier wieder, was ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe, der ist Ex-Fußballprofi. Das ist ein Muster, was sich durch diese Organisation zieht und auch insbesondere bei Fußball mit Vision. Da sitzen im Vorstand und im Kader von diesem Verein relativ viele Ex-Fußballer oder sogar zum Teil noch aktive FußballerInnen. Und ja, also Fußball mit Vision muss man wissen, die haben 60.000 Follower auf Instagram. Der Versprecher kommt, weil als wir angefangen haben, hatten diese um die 20.000, 30.000. Und wie gesagt, dass wir angefangen haben, die Texte zu schreiben, ist jetzt acht Monate her oder so. Also da gab es ein sehr, sehr großes Wachstum, ähnlich wie bei Ballers and God. Und insgesamt sehen Dina und ich auf jeden Fall, dass sie sich in den vergangenen Monaten sehr stark professionalisiert haben. Die haben ihren Website-Auftritt überarbeitet. Der sieht jetzt deutlich besser aus. Jetzt mal so wertend gesagt, die haben ihre Insta-Posts überarbeitet und deutlich mehr Reichweite insgesamt. Und die Missionierung funktioniert hier eigentlich same same wie bei Ballers and God. Also es gibt Posts von FußballerInnen, wie sie sich zum Glauben bekennen. Prominentes Beispiel, wieder ein Matcher. Oder wie gesagt, diese sogenannten Zeugnisvideos, die Fußballmitvisionen auf ihrem eigenen YouTube-Kanal hochladen, wo FußballerInnen oder zum Teil auch FunktionärInnen sich zum Glauben bekennen und ihren Glaubensweg erzählen. So weit unproblematisch erst mal.
Und sich wurden da Videos produziert. Bekanntere Namen, die da involviert sind, ist unter anderem Felix Udukay, der Mitgründer ist und im Vorstand sitzt. Eduard Löwen und Enrico Valentini. Also wir haben auch viele ehemalige oder aktuelle 60 Spieler mit drin. Und Giovanna Hofmann, die ich ja vorhin schon erwähnt habe, die ist auch bei Fußball mit Vision dabei. Und das ist jetzt aber so ein klassisches Beispiel, Dina, für eine Organisation, wo man auch auf den ersten Blick gar nicht so viele Anhaltspunkte für Kritik finden muss. Wenn man dann allerdings hört, dass zum Teil des Konzepts im Wesentlichen dazu gehört, junge Menschen dem christlichen Glauben näherzubringen, dann wird man schon ein bisschen vorsichtiger, eben wegen der Schutz junger Menschen. Und wenn man dann hört, dass dazu eben auch Fußballerbibeln verteilt werden und Schulen besucht werden, in denen diese Bibeln verteilt werden, wo ja nicht immer ganz klar ist, hat jetzt jeder Jugendliche und jeder hat da jeder jetzt zugestimmt, dass jetzt hier eine christliche Veranstaltung kommt mit einem visionarischen Eifer? Oder war das vielleicht die Idee von einigen wenigen? Dann wird das eben ein bisschen schwieriger auszuhalten, wenn man nicht ganz genau weiß, wofür Fußball mit Vision eigentlich stehen möchte. Wie gehst du denn damit um und lässt sich dazu eigentlich so stichfest etwas sagen? Welche Art des Glaubens Fußball mit Vision da verbreiten will?
Ja, es ist bei Fußball mit Vision ein bisschen komplizierter. Sie sind ein bisschen vorsichtiger als jetzt Bolles in God. Wir haben bei unserem zweiten Text, glaube ich, Felix, war das, komplett über Fußball mit Vision eigentlich geschrieben. Woher sie kommen, zu welchen Gruppierungen sie gehören. Sie haben eine gewisse Nähe zu Neues Leben. Das ist eine evangelikale Gruppierung. Die sind da ein bisschen verstrickt miteinander. Ich bin extra so ein bisschen nicht so ganz deutlich, weil das wirklich sehr kompliziert ist. Man sieht es wieder, wenn man tiefer geht, was sie genau machen. Sie haben im Team zum Beispiel einen U16-Trainer vom FC Augsburg, einen Nachwuchsleiter von Alemannien Aachen, die U19-Trainerin der Frauen-Nationalmannschaft. Es geht wieder, wie du gesagt hast, auf die Jugendlichen. Wenn ich ein konkretes Beispiel nennen darf, das ist Sima Susso von Fortuna Düsseldorf, ein Profi-Spieler. Der hat selbst gesagt, dass Manuel Bühler auf ihn zugekommen ist, ihn auf Instagram angeschrieben hat, weil er ein Bibel-Verse in der Biografie hatte und ihn dann mit zur Freikirche Köln-Ostheim genommen hat. Die Freikirche Köln-Ostheim hat öffentlich auf YouTube sehr queerveindliche Predigten, wo sie sich unter anderem als Sünde bezeichnen, unnatürlich oder auch sagen, dass homosexuelle Menschen ihre Orientierung verändern oder umkehren sollten. Sima Susso ist heute, wenn man auf die Homepage von Fussball mit Vision geht, bei Team, im Jugendbereich tätig. Seine Aufgabe ist eigentlich, die Jugendlichen zu Fussball mit Vision führen. Ich persönlich finde es wahnsinnig problematisch, wenn man dann in so einer Freikirche ist.
Oder sich zumindest nicht davon distanziert, was dort unter anderem gepredigt wird, Felix.
Ja, genau, im Grunde ist es wieder eine Parallele zu Ballos and God. Weil wir haben Manuel Bühler, der schon öfter für die Freikirche Köln-Ostheim als Redner auftrat. Und ich möchte noch mal den Punkt von Dina wirklich betonen. Also die haben eine schon, das muss man so sagen, sehr quälfeindliche Auslegung des Glaubens. Der Hauptprediger, ich mein es ist der Hauptprediger, der da predigt André Töfs. Der hat so was gesagt, was Dina gerade schon sagte, dass Homosexualität eine Sünde ist. Zitat, da predigt auch jemand wie Olaf Latzel regelmäßig. Olaf Latzel, der kommt tatsächlich aus meiner Gegend, hier kennt man den, aber weniger aus grümlichen Gründen. Der von CSD-Teilnehmerinnen, meine ich, als Degenerationsform der Gesellschaft gesprochen hat. Zitat. Und ein Beispiel, was ich jetzt noch anbringen wollte, ist Valentini. Was du schon meintest, der ist mit dem Vorstand von Fußball mit Vision und gleichzeitig U14-Trainer von Nürnberg. Und Valentini, da gab es Anfang des Jahres, das haben wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viele mitbekommen, aber um ihn gab es auch so einen Skandal, unter anderem auch Bild, die Bild-Zeitung aufgenommen hatte und zwar hatte er, um es wirklich sehr vorsichtig zu sagen, verwirrende Aussagen über Homosexualität gesagt. Im Grunde hat er sich ablehnend gegenüber Homosexualität geäußert und wie gesagt, es ist sehr problematisch, wenn so jemand gleichzeitig Trainer bei einer U14 in Nürnberg ist und da potenziell mutmaßlich Einfluss nehmen könnte auf SpielerInnen. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen weitergegriffen, aber es gibt gerade in der Bundesliga keinen einzigen geouteten Spieler und das hat sicherlich auch was damit zu tun, dass das auch aus solchen Gründen nicht akzeptiert werden würden.
Und das ist eben das, was Fußball mit Vision so interessant macht, dass eben hier so deutlich in den Jugend- und Nachwuchsbereich reingegangen wird. Wir haben auch Bernd Breitmaier mit dabei. Das ist ein Berater von Fußballer mit Vision. Fußball mit Vision, aber sind vielleicht auch Fußballer mit Vision, stimmt vielleicht auch darauf zu. Der ist inzwischen ein christlicher Berater. Das ist jetzt ein Zitat von ihm. Er hat das Nachwuchsleistungszentrum von Hannover 96 mit aufgebaut. Wir haben ja eben auch mit Melanie Behringer, die Coach des Frauen-Nationalteams der U19 beim DFB ist, jemanden, der dort arbeitet bei diesem Verband. Ich weiß, dass ihr all die betroffenen Organisationen konfrontiert habt und eben einfach nachgefragt habt, ob ihnen das bewusst ist und ob das zusammengeht mit den Werten der Organisation. Was hat denn der DFB in diesem Fall gesagt?
Ja, der DFB hat uns gegenüber betont, dass Behringers Glaube auf christlicher Nächsten, Liebe und Toleranz beruhe.
Und hat man sich geäußert zu, ob sie jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn sie lesbische Spielerinnen hätte, ob das für sie einfach so okay ist und das unberührt bleibt von ihrem persönlichen Glauben?
Sie haben sich auch relativ kurz gefasst. Sie haben uns einfach nur bestätigt, dass mein Behringer die Werte des Verbandes, wie Vielfalt und Respekt, lebe.
Und das wollen wir natürlich auch so akzeptieren. Aber das zeigt für euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, glaube ich, wie kritisch dieser ganze Bereich zu sehen ist. Weil dem kann natürlich so sein. Glaube ist, wie gesagt, Privatsache. Aber hier haben wir es eben mit der Einflussnahme von schutzbefohlenen Menschen zu tun. Und dann ist es eben doch nicht so klar, in welche Richtung das geht. Vor allem, wir haben ja schon rausgearbeitet, denn wir wissen, diese Gruppierungen arbeiten mit einem missionarischen Eifer und vertreten eben nicht immer liberale Themen. Und damit würde ich sagen, landen wir jetzt dann zum zehnten Mal bei Felix Nmecha. Und jetzt lasst doch mal drüber sprechen, was er so gesagt hat, was er getan hat und warum er eben für den deutschen Diskurs so wichtig ist. Weil wir haben ja schon rausgehört, also er war letztlich auch der Anstoß für eure Recherchen. Ich würde mal einen Zitat von ihm einspielen aus der Ballers in God Podcast Folge mit ihm, wo man so ein bisschen, ja ich glaube, einen Eindruck bekommt, wie er seinen Glauben versteht. Ich sage das jetzt einfach mal ganz wertneutral.
Ohne ihn hätte ich nicht die Chance. Und dann gibt er mir auch die Kraft, er gibt mir die Verbreitung, er gibt mir die Selbstverfassung, und all diese Dinge sind von Gott, deswegen verdient er die Glauben. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass Gott mich und die Fußballer die Wahrheit mit der Plattform teilen.
Halleluja, Mann! Halleluja!
Das ist so, so gut! Halleluja!
Also das kam wieder nicht von uns, aber das habt ihr glaube ich gehört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Vielleicht übernehme ich das in den Rasenfunk. Die machen das so häufig, dass sie am Ende eines Punkts, Denen, der je was andere sagt, Amen oder Hallelujah reinrufen. Also was hat Felix Nmecha hier gesagt? Er hat gesagt, er fühlt sich als von Gott berufen und deshalb wäre es eben aus seiner Ansicht nicht richtig einfach nur ein Fußballspieler zu sein, sondern eben mit dem, was er tut und damit auch indirekt mit seiner Reichweite, das ist jetzt eine Anmerkung meinerseits, eben das Wort Gottes zu verbreiten und eben den Glauben an Gott. Und da ist ja dann die Frage, Felix, wie macht denn das Felix Nmecha unter anderem so?
Also erst mal, du hast es schon gesagt, er sagt ganz offen, er hat eine klar missionarische Intention. Das macht er einerseits, indem er wie gesagt für diese zwei Gruppierungen auftritt, für Fußball mit Visionen, zum Beispiel Zeugnisvideos. Bei Bollas gegen Gott auch so eine Art Zeugnisvideos. Da leitet er meiner Meinung nach, Dina, korrigier mich, wenn ich falsch liege, auch so eine Bibelgruppe. Oder hat er es zumindest mal? Und ja, es zeigt halt einfach, meiner Meinung nach ist diese Vorbildfunktion sehr wirkmächtig und das Gefährliche daran. Was ich anfangs schon sagte, ich habe das Gefühl, dass gerade ein sehr junges Publikum das nicht auseinanderhalten kann, wenn ihr Vorbild etwas sagt, was man vielleicht nicht einfach so akzeptieren sollte. Und da in dem Moment dann nicht mehr den Fußballer von der Privatperson oder das Vorbild von dem Gesagten, besser gesagt, auseinanderhalten können. Die Missionierung findet sicherlich natürlich auch über sein Social Media statt. Also er hat eine verdammt große Reichweite auf Instagram. Ich weiß jetzt nicht im Kopf, wie viel Reichweite er hat, wie viele Followerin er hat. Aber auch darüber erreicht er viele Leute.
Und Dina, nachdem Felix Nmecha für dich der Anlass war, sich überhaupt mit diesem Thema auseinanderzusetzen. Also das, was wir hier gerade gehört haben, das hat er noch als Wolfsburg-Spieler gesagt vor seinem Wechsel zum BVB. Was waren denn die Dinge, über die du gestolpert bist, als du dich mit Felix Nmecha auseinandergesetzt hast?
Ja, das waren einerseits die beiden Instagram-Storyposts, die damals in den Medien waren. Also das war dieses Pride, was er mit dem Teufel gleichsetzt. Und dann war es noch eins, das habe ich jetzt gerade vergessen.
Er hat sich dann noch beim Tod von Charlie Kirk geäußert, das war aber später. Es gab noch verschiedene Likes für queerfeindliche Posts, in denen eben, also es gab einen Post, da schreibt jemand, jemand, der Christ ist, kann nicht schwul oder lesbisch sein. Und das zum Beispiel hat er gelesen.
Und ein Post von Matt Walsh.
Ja, genau, dieser Post von Matt Walsh war damals noch in den Medien. Ich habe da dann eben diesen Post gefunden, wo einer schreibt, dass man, wenn man Christ ist, nicht schwul oder lesbisch sein kann, weil man ja dann nicht in den Himmel kommt. Er hat viele Posts geliked, die Likes hat er dann allerdings alle entfernt oder entfernen lassen, ich weiß es nicht. Wo es halt auch darum ging, dass ein Homosexueller durch Gott dann heterosexuell wurde. Also es ging damals ziemlich in eine eindeutige Richtung. Und das war ja nicht alles. Man könnte ja meinen, okay, jetzt ist er bei Borussia Dortmund, es gab damals einen Skandal, es wurde richtig groß. Jetzt ist es gut, nein, eben da war dieser Charlie Kirk Post. Und dann dieses frauenfeindliche Buch, was er ja noch gelesen hat.
Könnte dazu noch kurz was sagen, weil das war jetzt ja kein Post, sondern man konnte es quasi in einer Story des BVB sehen, dass dieses Buch neben ihm lag. Was ist denn das für ein Buch? Also warum ist ein Buch an sich so schlimm?
Ja, also das Buch, das heisst Understanding the Purpose and Power of Woman, God's Design for Female Identity, das ist von Miles Monroe. Das ist ein evangelikaler Prediger und Pastor. Und in dem Buch erklärt er eigentlich die Rolle der Frau. Ihr merkt es vielleicht an meiner Stimme, dass ich das nicht so geil finde. Er sagt eigentlich, die Frau ist eine Verstärkerin des Mannes. Die Frau ist das Spiegelbild des Mannes und die Frau hat einfach die Aufgabe, eine Lebensspenderin zu sein, Kinder zu machen. Es bespricht auch, wie ein Mann sich einer Frau gegenüber zu verhalten hat. Ich habe das Buch gelesen, das muss man ihm zugestehen. Er sagt, wie sich ein Mann korrekt verhalten soll. Aber es bleibt die Rolle der Frau, sich unterzuordnen, ihren Mann unterzuordnen und wirklich ihre Rollen einzunehmen. Das finde ich sehr problematisch.
Unter anderem korrigiere ich mich, wenn ich das falsch herausgeschrieben habe, aber wird darin beschrieben, dass Frauen wie ein Rohmaterial, ich zitiere jetzt, sein, dass von den Männern geformt werden müsse. Also der Umgang wird einem beigebracht, aber auch, wie man quasi die Frauen zum eigenen Spiegelbild macht.
Genau, genau. Und wenn man das sieht, dass da ein Bundesligaprofi, ein ja, teilweise auch Nationalspieler, dieses Buch dann an einem öffentlichen Ort liest. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es im Teamhotel war, aber es war halt auf einer Terrasse, es war öffentlich einsehbar, man hat es ja eben auch nachher auf Social Media gefunden. Da frage ich mich dann auch wieder, wo ist die Vorbildfunktion?
Ich meine, man muss dazu sagen, das war jetzt kein Video, was er gepostet hat. Also er hat sich gesagt, hier, ich habe einen Buchtyp für euch, bitte lest mal dieses Video. Aber ich finde es halt insofern relevant und deswegen auch berichtenswert, weil Felix Nmecha nach allen Aufregern, die es um ihn gab, ich formuliere es jetzt flapsig mal als Aufreger, ja immer wieder betont hat, ich paraphrasiere jetzt, ja so habe ich es ja nicht gemeint, so schlimm, wie ihr es alle findet. Und dementsprechend ist dann die Frage, können wir ihm das glauben? Und wenn wir dann eben ein solches Buch bei ihm liegen sehen und eben dann jemand wie du dieses Buch auch komplett liest, ich ziehe sämtliche Hüte, die ich habe, ehrlich gesagt, wie du das durchgehalten hast, und dann eben sehen, was dort drin steht in einem solchen Buch, dann lässt das zumindest Zweifel zu, ob dem wirklich so ist, dass er manche Dinge, die er gemacht hat, nicht so gemeint hat. Ich meine, in diesem Buch wird die LGBTQ-Bewegung als Vergewaltigung der Bürgerrechtsbewegung bezeichnet. Also das ist jetzt auch kein Buch, wo man zwischen den Zeilen lesen muss, um rauszulesen, was dahinter der Sinn ist. Und deswegen, glaube ich, ist es auch okay, dass wir darüber reden, dass da einfach nur ein Buch neben Felix Nmecha lag. Felix?
Ich glaube, dieses Zitat, was du gerade angebracht hast mit der Vergewaltigung der Bürgerrechtsbewegung, das hat der Autor, der Prediger irgendwann mal so gesagt. Ich habe das Buch nicht gelesen, aber das ist nicht drin.
Das hat er mal gesagt.
Okay, gut, dass ihr das eingeordnet habt. Sorry, das sieht man mal. Das ist gut. Obwohl man versucht sauber zu arbeiten, rutscht einem dann sowas durch. Wir hören mal kurz einen weiteren Ausschnitt von Felix Nmecha, wie er sich geäußert hat im Bollers in God Podcast.
Das ist etwas, das Gott mir letztes Jahr wirklich geholfen hat. Dodi Lukabaki war auch bei mir in Wolfsburg. Er ist ein anderer Bollers in God-Member. Wir haben uns alle geholfen und wir haben so viele Erinnerungen während der Saison bekommen. Einer der größten Erinnerungen, die wir bekommen, war, dass wir leben und spielen durch das Ziel, nicht durch die Gelegenheit. So lange ich hart arbeite, so lange ich in Gott abide, werde ich mein Ziel erreichen. Diese zwei Schläge waren wirklich wichtig für mein Entwicklung.
Alter, das ist so krass.
Das war eine Bar, Alter.
Sag das mal noch einmal für die Leute.
Wir leben durch das Ziel und nicht durch die Möglichkeit.
Amen.
Also was hat Felix Nmecha hier ganz kurz gesagt? Im Grunde hat er gesagt, jedes Mal, wenn ich den Platz betrete, dann spiele ich nicht für mich, sondern ich spiele für God. Das hätte er eben gelernt in einer härteren Zeit bei Wolfsburg. Damals hatte er nicht so viel Einsatzzeit und dass man eben für sein Schicksal lebe, für seine Bestimmung lebe. Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich die korrektere Übersetzung hier und nicht für die Möglichkeit und dann Klammer auf, Geld zu verdienen, Tore zu erzielen, Titeln und Trophäen zusammen. Dina, wenn man jemandem so sprechen hört, verändert das auch die Art und Weise, wie wir über ihn als Fußballspielenden denken sollten? Wenn er sagt, jedes Mal wenn ich auf den Platz gehe, ist das, okay, ich überspitze jetzt, ist das quasi wie ein Gottesdienst?
Das ist eine schwierige Frage. Ich denke nicht, weil da sind wir ja wieder bei dem Persönlichen. Sein Glaube ist, auch wenn er evangelikal sein sollte und auch wenn er all diese Ansichten, die man ihm vorwirft, hat, was man ja nicht zu 100%ig weiss, ist sein Glaube immer noch persönlich für Felix Nmecha. Und wenn er für sich sagt, ich gehe nur aus diesem Grund auf den Platz und spiele Fußball, dann finde ich das okay.
Felix, hast du da Gedanken zu?
Ich sehe das eigentlich genauso wie Dina. Ich würde vielleicht noch auf eine andere Stelle von diesem Zitat zu sprechen kommen, die du jetzt so gar nicht übersetzt hast. Und zwar sagt er ja auch wieder, dass es solange er richtig glaubt an Gott, dass es sportlich auch läuft. Das sagt er so, wenn mich mein Englisch jetzt nicht völlig im Stich gelassen hat. Und das ist das, was ich Anfang schon sagte, dass Dina und ich glauben, dass das dieses wirkmächtige Versprechen ist, was einige dieser Kreise implizit oder explizit geben. Wenn du richtig glaubst, richtig auslebst, dann läuft es sportlich auch bei dir. Und das sieht man, dass das scheinbar bei EMM so im Kopf festgesetzt ist. Das finde ich ganz interessant hervorzuheben.
Ja, kann ich noch hinzufügen, dass es, wenn er selbst das für sich sagt, finde ich das völlig okay. Wenn jetzt er aber sagt, mein Mitspieler, der auch gläubig ist, hey, du schießt die Tore, du hast nur Erfolg, weil Gott das will, dann finde ich es wieder nicht okay, weil es dann eigentlich den eigenen Erfolg, die eigentliche Arbeit schweckt und eigentlich alles Gott zuschiebt, sozusagen.
Ich finde, es zeigt halt, warum im Leistungssport das so anschlussfähig ist. Weil im Leistungssport du die ganze Zeit mit Erfolg und Versagen zu tun hast, mit Gelingen und Nicht-Gelingen, mit Sieg und Niederlage. Und wenn du dann in allem, sowohl im Sieg als auch in der Niederlage, immer etwas Höheres erkennen kannst, dich letztlich damit ja auch emotional distanzieren kannst, was dir helfen kann im Leistungssport, dann hat das eine extreme Wirkmacht. Und deswegen ist das, glaube ich, auch gerade im Fußball eben so anschlussfähig und gerade bei jungen Spielern, weil die genau damit normalerweise ihre Kämpfe haben. Wie gehe ich damit um mit Rückschlägen? Und das müssen nicht immer nur Verletzungen sein, sondern eben auch Dinge, die auf dem Feld passieren. Und gleichzeitig steckt dann aber hinter vielem, was Felix Nmecha so glaubt, dann doch eine dichotome Weltsicht, nenne ich es mal. Auf der einen Seite ist Gott, und auf der anderen Seite ist der Teufel.
Und obwohl wir uns immer sagen können, wir haben die Waffe gewonnen, das ist wahr, wir haben die Waffe gewonnen. Aber wir haben nicht alle Waffen gewonnen. Deswegen müssen wir diese Wahrheit erinnern, weil der Teufel da ist.
Also selbst wenn man als Christ sagen könnte, wir haben den Krieg gewonnen, aber die schlachten noch nicht alle, denn der Teufel, er ist immer noch da und deshalb müssen wir weiter die Botschaften von Gott und Jesus weitertragen. Und da sieht man eben, Felix, da hat das eine ganz andere Tonalität. Und deswegen habe ich diese, diese, diese... Ich hab mir schon mehrere O-Töne mitgebracht, weil man eben merkt, auf einmal wirkt Felix Nmecha ganz anders, wenn er so etwas sagt im Vergleich zu dem, wo wir alle vorher auch gesagt hätten, ja ist er völlig okay, wenn er halt an Gott glaubt, während er Fußball spielt.
Ja, das ist irgendwie so ein ganz klassisches Weltendungsszenario, was hier aufgemacht wird, was natürlich Leute unter Druck setzen kann. Und er bezieht sich da auf den Teufel. Und jetzt, wenn man das mal zurückbezieht auf diesen Post, den er da in seiner Story mal gemacht hat, wo die Pride-Bewegung meines Erachtens nach wirklich unmissverständlich die Pride-Bewegung, also die LGBTQ-Bewegung nur gemeint gewesen sein kann, mit dem Teufel verglichen wird, stellt sich natürlich der Frage, wen sieht denn Nmecha jetzt als Teufel? Wer ist für ihn der Teufel? Also, wer ist Auslöser für dieses Weltendungsszenario, für dieses ganz düstere Szenario, was er da zeichnet? Und ja, das finde ich sehr bedenklich.
Deswegen wollte ich es in dieser Reihenfolge mitbringen. Und Dina, du darfst dann gerne zum letzten, also ich verspreche, ist jetzt auch der letzte Otto von Felix Nmecha, dass ich noch zu äußern. Denn wir haben ja gesehen, es gab Kontroverse. Man muss noch dazu sagen, dass das ist alles passiert dann, als er dann Spieler bei Dortmund war. Also das meiste davon ist dann passiert. Dortmund hat irgendwann dann auch durchgesetzt. Okay, wenn du selber was posten willst, gucken wir nochmal drüber. Ist natürlich toll, dass man auf diese Art und Weise darauf reagiert, indem man sagt, wir wollen nicht, dass du nochmal einen Fehler machst. Interessant finde ich aber, dass Felix Nmecha sich genau dazu geäußert hat, nämlich zu der Frage, wie trete ich denn eigentlich in der Öffentlichkeit auf, wenn ich meine Botschaft unters Volk bringen möchte? Hören wir mal rein.
Ich glaube, dass es eine Balance von Wissen und Wahrheit gibt, in der ich glaube, dass es Situationen gibt, in denen wir nicht so gut darüber reden, dass es nicht so witzig ist, das zu sagen.
Aus der Sicht nach würde Gott von ihm fordern, dass er eine Balance findet zwischen Wahrheiten und dem Teilen dieser Wahrheiten, dass es einen Moment gäbe, Wahrheiten nicht zu teilen, vor allem bei Themen, die er nennt, sie touchy sind, also vielleicht ein bisschen kritikfähiger. Was könnte er damit nur meinen? Vielleicht hast du dazu auch Gedanken. Und dass er es aber so empfindet, dass es letztlich seine Aufgabe ist, im Namen Gottes, sich auch als öffentliche Figur zu solchen Themen zu äußern. Wie denkst du dazu?
Ja, also mit seinen touchy Themen denke ich, meint er schon auch die queeren Themen und die frauenfeindlichen Themen. Ich glaube, das ist das Einzige, was so ein bisschen touchy ist. Man sieht es ja, er spricht von der Wahrheit und er spricht von seiner und Gottes Wahrheit. Ich glaube auch, dass er das glaubt. Er ist davon überzeugt, dass in der Bibel, das, was dort steht zu diesen Themen, dass das die Wahrheit ist und dass es seine Aufgabe als öffentliche Person ist, das auch auszusprechen. Und den Menschen zu zeigen, dass wir jetzt eigentlich auf einem falschen Weg sind.
Auf dem aus seiner Sicht falschen Weg, natürlich. Und eigentlich Felix muss man ihm ja dankbar sein, dass er das so offen mal gesagt hat, weil damit ist er klar, er ist sich völlig bewusst, was er tut.
Ja, das denke ich auch. Also bei Nmecha ist es spätestens nachdem es, also es gab mehrere Entschuldigungen und nach diesen Entschuldigungen sind trotzdem immer wieder Sachen passiert. Der letzte Stand war, das ist wieder mal seitens des BVBs die Aussage gab, wir suchen das Gespräch mit ihm und es wird aber auch öffentlich überhaupt nicht kommuniziert, was bedeutet ist, dass das Gespräch gesucht wird, was ist das Resultat davon. DFB hat einen ähnlichen O-Ton gegeben. Und ich persönlich finde das irgendwie einfach schrecklich, weil ich meine, der BVB ist ein Verein, der sich ja Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Danke höhe, für die nächste Liebe und Borussia verbindet, Stichwort Borussia verbindet einsetzt. Also Nmecha als Person widerspricht dem ja, also fundamental in diesem Grundsatz, den der BVB propagiert. Und das finde ich, um ehrlich zu sein, sehr fragwürdig. Natürlich ist es irgendwie schwierig, einen Umgang damit zu finden. Also soll man den jetzt rauswerfen? Das wird realistisch gesehen auch niemals passieren. Aber ja, also das ist meine persönliche Meinung. Ich denke, er ist sich schon sehr sicher, was er davon sich gibt und was er sagt.
Und das ist ja auch einer der Gründe, Dina, warum wir jetzt Felix Nmecha hier so oft nennen, weil er derjenige ist, der am öffentlichsten mit seiner Meinung sich äußert. Bei vielen, vielen anderen können wir Vermutungen anstellen, wie wohl so ihr missionarischer Eifer, den sie ja haben, also den haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, bei allen, die wir so genannt haben, weil das ja auch Teil der Netzwerke ist, in denen sie stecken. Aber welche, welche Glaubensüberzeugung damit verbunden sind, das ist eben von außen nicht zu beurteilen. Aber Felix Nmecha, der hat sich eben geäußert. Er hat sich queerfeindlich geäußert. Er ist vermutlich auch eher einem tradierten Rollenbild zwischen Männern und Frauen anhängig. Und letztlich wird aber ja dann an diesem sehr prominenten Fall gezeigt. So richtig was passiert ist ja nicht.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Und ich kann sagen, als BVB-Fan, ich habe oft das Gespräch gesucht mit dem Verein. Intern hat man das Problem wahrscheinlich schon gesehen, aber machen konnte trotzdem niemand was. Und jetzt gerade auch die Vertragsverlängerung, diesen Frühling mit ihm, zeigt ja auch, dass er zwar gegen fast alle Werte vom Verein verstösst, aber solange es sportlich funktioniert, ist das völlig egal. Und das ist einfach, ich sage es jetzt ein bisschen böse, ich glaube als queere Fan darf ich das schon auch so sagen. Das ist einfach ein Witz und man kann den BVB und seine Werte so einfach auch nicht ernst nehmen.
Was uns zum letzten Punkt bringt, Felix, kannst du gerne gleich mal anschließen, nämlich der Frage, ja welche Verantwortung tragen denn dann Spielerinnen, Vereine und Verbände?
Ja, also zur Personalie, ein Matcher würde ich noch einmal gerne ergänzen. Es gab jetzt neulich die Vertragsverlängerung. Das ist meiner Meinung nach bei dieser Geschichte auch nicht irrelevant. Also der BVB hat den Vertrag mit Felix Nmecha verlängert, ihn zum Topverdiener gemacht und im Prinzip eigentlich zum Aushängeschild. Das kann man schon so zynisch sagen. Also es gibt scheinbar auch nicht irgendwie das Interesse, wenigstens zu sagen, ja, er passt nicht zu unseren Werten. Dann sollten wir ihn vielleicht verkaufen. Das ist noch irgendwie die einvernehmlichste Art und Weise, mit dieser Geschichte umzugehen. Das gibt es nicht. Also ohne Verein und Verbände geht diese ganze Geschichte einfach nicht. Das muss man, das muss man so sagen. Es müssen klare Signale vom Verein, von den Verbänden kommen, bezüglich des Schutzes von Spielerinnen, vor allen Dingen Nachwuchsleistungszentren, aber auch eben klare Konsequenzen. Bisher gab es es eigentlich, wenn überhaupt, von Seiten der Fangemeinden kommuniziert, sei es durch Spruchbanner oder zum Teil, wo Dina und ich jetzt eingeladen wurden, von irgendwelchen Faninitiativen. Aber so richtig von Seiten der Vereine gab es eigentlich, ehrlich gesagt, überhaupt kein Interesse daran, dieses Thema anzugehen.
Warum, Dina, glaubst du, ist das so?
Ja, das ist die große Frage. Ich denke, bei gewissen Vereinen kann man es schon ein bisschen so nennen, dass sie die Werte nur aufgestellt haben, weil es gesellschaftlich ein bisschen verlangt wurde in den letzten Jahren. Ich glaube, es gibt Vereine, die fühlen oder leben nicht, was in den Werten steht. Dann gibt es die Vereine, die wahrscheinlich ein bisschen überfordert sind mit dem Thema, eben weil es ja die Religionsfreiheit betrifft. Und nicht recht wissen, was man überhaupt darf. Darf man jetzt einem Spieler verbieten, öffentlich über seinen Glauben, auch wenn er diskriminierend ist, zu sprechen oder nicht? Ich denke, das sind so ein bisschen die Gründe. Und es gibt da einerseits eben die Vereine sind in der Pflicht, die Spieler zu schützen, aufzuklären zu solchen Themen. Eine andere Plattform zu nehmen, also den Glauben und das Bedürfnis zu glauben, ernst nehmen und das ein bisschen zu leiten, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Und andererseits halt auch wirklich solche diskriminierenden Aussagen, auch wenn sie in der Bibel stehen, zu benennen und zu beurteilen.
Man könnte ja sogar das jetzt noch einen Schritt weitergedacht. Man kann ja auch diese christlichen, diese christlichen Aussagen aus der Bibel, die selbst kann man ja auch in den Kontext setzen. Denn das, finde ich, ist das Interessante. Wir werden dazu verleitet, dadurch, dass wir diesen Menschen jetzt in dieser Sendung so viel zugehört haben und so viel mit ihm beschäftigt haben. Irgendwann interpretiert man auch jeden Satz, so wie in der Bibel steht. Und dann vergisst man eben genau das, was eigentlich alle Theologen, die eben nicht zu solchen evangelikalischen oder charismatischen oder pfingstlichen Bewegungen gehören. Niemand versteht die Bibel absolut wörtlich. Sie wird immer in einen Kontext gesetzt. In den Kontext der Zeit, zum Beispiel, gibt es viele Theologinnen und Theologen, die alles, was über Homosexualität in der Bibel gesagt wird, auch darunter verstehen, dass Homosexualität damals auch bedeutet hat, dass man Ehebruch begangen hat und dass es eben nicht um eine langfristige Beziehung ging, um ein gemeinsames Leben, sondern, also jetzt ganz verkürzt gesagt, um den Seitensprung und vielleicht auch daher so manche Formulierung in der Bibel kam. Da wird natürlich endlos drüber gestritten und es ist schwierig und letztlich ist es eine mündlich überlieferte Geschichte, die irgendwann verschriftlicht wurde. Aber sogar das wäre ja möglich. Man könnte ja als Verein auch so etwas anbieten, sich darüber in den Austausch zu begeben. Und wenn du dann feststellst, dass gegenüber in dem Fall dann ein Spieler oder ein Trainer, eine Trainerin, die machen zu und die vertreten eine radikale Auslegung des Christentums, die sich eben mit unseren Grundrechten, mit dem Grundgesetz widerspricht, dann hast du ja auch eine Legitimation zu handeln und vielleicht daraus auch Konsequenzen zu ziehen. Und das finde ich immer wieder bemerkenswert, dass es eigentlich gar nicht so schwierig ist, die Werte, die man vorgibt, dann auch zu leben. Und du bist dafür, wenn du für eine diskriminierungsfreie Welt bist, und das würde jeder Verein von sich behaupten, jeder Verband behauptet das von sich, jede Liga behauptet das von sich aktuell, hier in Deutschland zumindest, dann bist du ja dazu verpflichtet, den entsprechenden Safe Space für alle betroffenen Gruppen zu schaffen. Und wenn du das konsequent durchsetzt, dann müsstest du eigentlich auch automatisch sehr unattraktiv sein für Menschen, denen das komplett gegen den Strich geht. Also man könnte auch, glaube ich, über so fast wie ein magnetisches Feld, das sich aufbaut. Und gewisse Dinge kannst du dann damit gar nicht mehr anziehen, die stößt du ab, nämlich den genauen Gegenpol dazu. Ich weiß nicht, Felix, ob das jetzt irgendwie zu utopisch ist, ob das zu metaphorisch gedacht ist. Ich fühle mich gerade wie Christian Ilzer, sorry. Aber so könnte man dem Ganzen ja auch begegnen. Lebt eure Werte halt auch im Alltag?
Auf jeden Fall. Es ist wahrscheinlich schon utopisch. Ich halte es nicht für realistisch, dass es jetzt passieren wird. Der zentrale Konflikt, der wahrscheinlich bei vielen Vereinen ist, zeigt sich auch wieder an Nmecha. Nmecha liefert ja absolute Leistung bei BVB jetzt die letzten Jahre. Und da ist eben dieser Konflikt, was soll man mit jemandem machen, der im Fußball Leistung bringt. Es geht um Leistung, Punkt. Das ist vielleicht nochmal eine andere Sache. Es gibt ja offensichtlich dieses Bedürfnis nach Spiritualität. Das ist, was ich vorhin schon angesprochen habe, was ist jetzt fast schon eine philosophische Frage, aber was ja scheinbar menschen verankert ist, sicherlich auch bei FußballerInnen. Und da sollten die Vereine und Verbände meiner Meinung nach dafür sorgen, dass für Fußballinnen, auch Nachwuchsfußballinnen, es irgendwelche Angebote gibt, die außerhalb dieser Kreise, außerhalb dieser zumindest mal dubiosen Kreise gibt, um es vorsichtig zu formulieren. Das gibt es sicherlich schon, aber irgendwas hindert es ja daran, also irgendwas hindert die FußballerInnen ja daran, dahin zu gehen, statt irgendwie sich dubiosen Netzwerken anzuschließen. Was auch immer die Komponente jetzt sein mag.
Zu diesem utopischen Szenario, was ich ziemlich geil fände, man kann es ein bisschen mit St. Pauli vergleichen. St. Pauli lebt ja eigentlich seine Werte ziemlich öffentlich aus und auch verreinsintern, so was ich halt so mitkriege. Und selbst sie haben Mitglieder von Ballers in God, die bei ihm spielen, die bei ihm gespielt haben. Zum Beispiel Eric da Silva Moreira, oder wie man es ausspricht. Ist ja auch DFB-Nationalspieler. Und es hat ihn auch nicht davon abgehalten, obwohl er in diesem sehr offenen Verein groß geworden ist, zu Ballers in God zu gehen. Ich weiss nicht, ob das alleine reicht. Aber ich denke, es würde natürlich die Einflussnahme ein bisschen bremsen. Von diesen Communities.
Ja, und ich glaube, so ein bisschen kann man Gedanken durch den Bärenfall bei Wolfsburg. Also wenn sich ein Spieler weigert, ein Regenbogentrikot zu unterschreiben und indem er das auch beschimpft und verunglimpft, dann ist es ja, also dann alles, was danach gekommen ist, muss thematisiert werden. Also dass das erst intern gelöst werden sollte und der VfL Wolfsburg schon ein bisschen öffentlich Druck gebraucht hat, sich dazu zu verhalten. Aber das eigentlich Gute ist ja, dass dieser Spieler dieses Regenbogentrikot unterschreiben sollte, denn da hat sich seine Gesinnung gezeigt. Das ist ihm gegen den Strich gegangen. Wenn er das Szeneknischen signiert, ist mir das ja auch völlig egal, weil damit wird ja gezeigt, das ist halt einfach, wir glauben daran. Ich meine, ich würde das jetzt auch gar nicht auf dieses Symbol der Regenbogenflagge, da könnte man jetzt auch ganz lange drüber sprechen, wie man das persönlich findet. Aber das meine ich, konfrontiert einfach Menschen mit einer gelebten Realität, die eben diskriminierungsfrei ist. Und dann glaube ich, dass klar, kannst du dann immer noch ein Baller in Gott sein. Es kann auch sein, dass du das alles erträgst. Aber dann ist ja eigentlich auch nichts passiert, denn wir wollen ja eine diskriminierungsfreie Welt. Und nur darauf haben wir ja auch einen Anspruch. Was jeder Mensch für sich glaubt, das haben wir ja schon oft genug jetzt gesagt. Es ist ja seine oder ihre Sache. Felix, du wolltest was ergänzen?
Ja, ich habe eine gute Idee. Gebt Felix Nmecha doch einfach mal eine Regenbogenkapitän. Das würde mal schauen, was dann passiert. Das wäre ja genau die Taktik, die du jetzt beschreibst.
Ich möchte mich dazu nicht weiter äußern.
Ich bringe es in den Raum, also ich finde es auch nicht schlecht.
Wir denken nur, so wie die lieben Ballers in Gott einfach nur beten.
Kann man so sagen.
Ihr zwei, das war eine anspruchsvolle Sendung. Auch, weil wir hier ein paar technische Probleme hatten. Also liebe YouTube-Zusehende, da gab es so den einen oder anderen Schnitt. Das hatte hier mit sehr, sehr wankelmütigem Internet zu tun. Dina hat vorhin schon in einer der Unterbrechungen gesagt, da ist uns der Heilige Geist ins W-Lang gefahren. Vielleicht war das, war dem auch so. Dem spüren wir nach. Ich danke euch beiden sehr, sehr herzlich für eure Zeit, für eure Recherchen. Wie gesagt, nochmal der Hinweis. Ich werde alles verlinken, wo man das lesen kann. Und ich kann alle Zuhörenden da draußen nur auffordern, bleibt an dem Thema dran, denn es hat eine ganz eigene Dynamik. Das habt ihr an den Followerzahlen, die wir vorhin immer mal wieder haben fallen lassen, gemerkt. Die sind rasant gestiegen in den letzten Monaten. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Dina Falken. Dina, danke, dass du dich des Themas angenommen hast und hier im Rasenfunk warst.
Sehr gerne.
Und herzlichen Dank an Felix Michaelis. Schön, dass du hier mit dabei warst, Felix. Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, was ihr noch so alles rausrecherchiert in der Zukunft.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung. Habe mich gefreut.
Mich ebenso. Und dann danke ich natürlich auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern. Denn ihr wisst ja, eine Sendung wie diese hier, paywall, werbe- und sponsorenfrei, die ist nur durch euch möglich. Alles hier im Rasenfunk ist von euch finanziert. Dementsprechend können wir auch den unabhängigsten Journalismus umsetzen, den man sich vorstellen kann. Also hier spricht niemand in die Themenfindung mit rein. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die uns unterstützt haben. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr in der Video- und der Podcastbeschreibung. Oder wenn ihr auf rasenfunk.de geht und dort auf den Unterstützen-Button klickt. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Läuft bei mir, Daniel, bei Henning, bei Nils, bei Bananenflanke123 und bei Les-Inc. Sie alle haben sich auch als Supportende registriert und so konnte ich sie hier nach dem Zufallsprinzip nennen. Wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Folge, dann sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de versucht, die Grautöne zu sehen. Auch die Grautöne, die wir hier in unserer Diskussion hatten. Und dann bin ich aber sehr gespannt, was ihr zu dieser Sendung hier sagt. Würde mich freuen, wenn ihr den Rasenfunk weiterempfehlt, diese Sendung hier weiterempfehlt und hört auch gerne in unsere anderen Formate rein. In diesem Sinne, bleibt oder werdet gesund und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.
Ciao!
Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Psst, Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knauser.
Genau.